wait wait are you guys on are you guys on stream yeah i'm live i'm live yeah i'm live don't docks yourself my address is here it's all no do you guys remember that time i gave you my credit card information i'm gonna say it again oh good because i i need it yeah okay cool cool yeah yeah yeah the last four digits of jama's credit card is five wow hello hi everybody after the five five oh yeah five hello hello welcome in i'm gonna unmute so that we can keep keep on that's also the last four digits of your fucking yeah my code my british code yeah i can never break british code it's the code what does the code i'm hacking i'm hacking the code i'm sleep deprived dokey out here trying to like figure out what british people have instead of social security numbers it didn't work the can the post has been down for so long like i forgot what it's called oh my god we've been on we've been can has been on strike for the for the post office for like a year now like almost two years i don't even
know what it's called anymore yeah we were you get mad okay huh do you get mail still oh no not if you use canna You gotta use like UPS or in, you gotta use UPS and FedEx and all the other shit.
That's how bad it is.
I know it's crazy.
It's cause like, um, we were on strike and then the, I guess the prime minister was like, don't worry, we'll fix this.
Just, we'll fix this later.
My chat is yelling at me to tell you to start your stream doki.
Okay.
I'm trying to give you guys little hats.
Give me a, give us little hats.
When you, instead of going live, you were decorating our Fugies?
Yes, I'm decorating our Fugies.
No, don't worry, it'll be worth it.
I'm giving you guys little hats.
Uh-huh.
Sorry, everybody, we started the collab 45 minutes late because Doki is the color coordinator.
Doki's playing Barbies.
Okay, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Also, by the way, I just realized I didn't even download the game, and I suggested the game.
this is not going to be one of those like guys you have to play the 20 minute tutorial before i don't know i don't i don't loaded it but i haven't found a tutorial yeah guys we're doing a live again like did you did you buy burger but burger but burger but okay thank you okay i saw it i saw i saw it before but i saw the thumbnail i was like that can't be the right game right The thing I didn't do is I didn't make a fucking graphic though,
so hold on.
We're doing it live.
We were like betting on the fact that it was, okay, I'm ripping it live with no waiting room.
And I haven't bought the game yet too, but that's fine.
I just got this.
Do you have like the blank burger bots thing that you used for your announcement and can I steal it?
You're just gonna yonk it?
I'm gonna yonk it.
It's just the title of the game, man.
I'm gonna put my VTuber on there instead.
and be like look at my homework man i didn't copy and paste your face off over it too if you want oh yeah i could give you like the psd or something if you want yeah i have one with my face on it too if you want so you can just copy and paste your face onto this one and then swap my face to yours oh i have a thumbnail maker because i can't be bothered but i need i need to get like a formal I don't plan what I'm doing in advance.
I basically go live and I'm like, chat, what should I do today?
And at that point, I'm already like, you know, I can't make a thumbnail at that point.
I'm fucked.
Oh my God.
Yeah, like, yeah, I think I schedule shit.
So I at least my thumbnail maker can be like, I like making thumbnails.
I think it's fun.
Okay, then.
Okay, I'm so surpassed.
God, you're so annoying.
Oh my God.
Like, work.
face harassment please I'm just here to flip some burgers this person going above and beyond and making us look bad oh I was like okay using her time productively didn't take a fucking two-hour nap before the collab okay that's your problem though is you took a two-hour nap you're supposed to only take like a 30 minute that's why she's crazy hold on do you have like do you have like a really shitty png of your face so i can paste you over me and then i'll paste me over you specifically me give me a second yeah don't worry i need to put your face on me and my face on you so i got you give me a second thank you what is uh where the is it here's okay i got you thank you appreciate you all right there we go perfect i love me on my screen no it needs to be the face because that's literally you at the moment oh wait i should oh my tomato doesn't have the tired face i didn't have eye back wait i have to see the tomato i'm pulling your stream up are you live give you guys yeah i'm live now i'm
gonna give you guys little hats give me i'm still missing there you go i'm gonna have to like tilt myself to like oh my god this is insane face
I'm gonna show the chat.
It looks like you just walked behind, like, I went to 7-Eleven and you just, like, quartered me into the alley.
And you're just like, hey, guys.
No, no, what's that game?
Like, no, I'm not a human?
Oh, no.
That's that Stokey showing up at the door.
Yeah.
I'm not okay.
I'm sorry.
I don't know why.
Okay.
I'm sorry.
Okay, I'm trying to make, like, Nimi's Fugi to work, but she doesn't, like, Fugi refuses to, like, her appear on my screen wait i thought i was the one not appearing no you're you're on it you know like when you post the the fugie link and then like she doesn't they don't show up like i'm not coming to work today guys i'm saying i don't want to play burgers she already missed the first day of work oh man there's your thumbnail editor to try hard and put a filter on our png so this is i'm not replicating this very well so bye whatever a good amount of money Yeah,
if I could try it.
Try hard.
Sorry for paying my thumbnail maker.
It's fine.
No, don't worry about it.
It'll look better for the lack of actual effort put into this edit.
Yeah, exactly.
It's funnier like that.
Okay, guys.
I'm still trying to get Mimi onto my screen.
Do you want a PNG or something?
Okay, I got her in.
Okay.
I have to like make a new one.
I think it's your fault, Doki.
How is it my fault?
I just want to give you guys little hats, though.
I have, like, four ears because your ears are so big, I can't cover them without making me impossibly huge.
So now I have, like, ferret ears and cat ears sticking out from them, so that's fine.
That's the new meta.
Everyone becomes a cat, girl.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, man, we want to explain the game we were originally going to play.
You know how people thought we were going to do a severance watch a party?
Is that what they thought?
god that was like a whole show called severance yeah we're gonna watch party severance or some no it was a game i uh it was a game where it's literally phasmophobia but someone can play as the ghost and i was like reading comments from like the dev and it seemed like they were like people were like they should add this to phasmophobia and they were like i already tried to tell them to add this and they said they'll never do it so i did it myself
crazy so i was like oh well that seems kind of silly but now we're back in the kitchen yeah and then it seemed like they had their shit together until like you know like i was gonna fucking download the game like two days before and then i was like why does this just say it's 2025 it is what do you mean it is 2025
the date of like um of when it's gonna show up so i just got so confused i was like we did it not tell us the release date why the fuck did we organize this collab on saturday like no there is yeah there was a release date and then it disappeared yeah he posted an update it was like something there was like a some bug with his build and so steam rejected it yeah like i had to look it up on because i was like trying to find like dev's fucking social media platform and his only social media platform was tick tock for some reason okay but i find so many games on tick tock okay like this game i found it on tick tock was he using his real voice or was he using the ai voiceover i have to know i don't remember just the text it was like this game is gonna be delayed because they don't check games on the weekend i was like yeah gross um we might need a swap game we're in trouble yeah god forbid steam staff have the weekends off wait wait wait so does that mean like they didn't bother like
uploading their builds in advance they apparently uploaded it on thursday or so like late night at thursday and then so then they're like guys i don't think they're checking the games like they're like oh it takes like five days to approve a game and so they're like we i don't think they're gonna be able to finish checking the game like yeah oops oh well this looks fun too okay i finished my thumbnail if you finished putting hats on everybody yeah we all have hats yeah okay what does the thumbnail look like i want to see oh i posted it in discord it's really high effort oh yeah oh it looks good it looks good i actually couldn't tell yeah but the fact that they're filming completely differently
Your big ears!
Oh, I love your four-year look.
Oh, wow, I got new outfit debut, outfit upgrade.
I'll show the chat.
All right, who's going to make the server?
Who's going to host it?
Who's in the middle?
The regional manager.
Oh, I'm in the middle.
I could try.
Oh, yeah, so, yeah.
Okay, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
Manager Mint also has like a nice flow to it.
Manager Minto.
Yeah, the regional.
I'm gonna cap the frame rate on this game because every like every one of these games that we play that's like early access and stuff is like hey what's optimization and if you don't cap the frame rate it just like eats your computer.
I didn't see an option.
Oh I just do it through the Nvidia control panel.
Oh wait there's there's like there's proximity chat here.
Wait there's push this up.
It says it's recommended too.
It says proximity is recommended.
Oh so we're doing the mute.
Okay I can't wait for the next cool I didn't realize we did that.
I didn't think that would mean me.
Every time.
Wait, there's only push to talk.
You can't even do open mic.
What the fuck?
There's no open mic.
Wait, isn't there?
I've made it.
I'm gonna put that on my mouse button.
This is, wait, if I uncheck push to talk, maybe, maybe.
I'm gonna uncheck push to talk and see.
Alright, now I'm starting to send invites now.
I'm launching the game.
If I disappear, it's because I crashed.
I gotta... I just realized I have to unprivate my friends list so I can join your lobby.
I saw you though, but I don't see...
I don't see Lymo and I don't see Snuffy.
I'm still just launching the game.
Also, I'm on Invisible, so give me a minute.
Yeah, we don't... We don't want people to know what we're doing.
I bet you... She doesn't want people to know she's playing Orch Massage.
Sometimes I hear that Mint plays V Bridger.
What a freak.
Oh yeah, the mic.
make me go online why i'm not regular it's i think it's not push the talk and then you can activate push to talk yeah yeah yeah you can take push the talk if you want to yeah yeah but how do you then like what's okay i will see you guys in game i guess okay i need me can you uh invite me it again my invite's not working yeah mine is an either i'm sending i'm sending it's doing the thing oh it's doing the thing because it says you're in vbridger we can't join oh no wait what do i do wait i'm looking at browse games and i don't even see your lobby usually you have because i turned it in by oh i'll leave it i'll and i'll do friends only friend your soul friends only
guys why would you think i don't have friends okay i did friends so you guys can probably find me searching for games no games found searching for games no games found me too uh what you can do is if you add vbridger to your private games on steam it won't show people you're playing it which will then make it so that it shows burger box oh you right-click it oh yeah on vbriger and steam be like right click is it properties oh hi this game yeah yeah oh wait and mark is private mark is mark is private yeah do you just hide it from yourself i love vbriger anymore mark is private okay now no one will ever know no one will know No.
This is where we have to, like, Steam has to actually restart, because it still says you're playing V Bridger, but...
Oh, uh-oh.
I have to restart.
I may see.
Maybe Lyme should be the regional manager.
I think Lyme is way more capable than me.
How much, like, ping do you really need to play this game?
It'll be fine, man.
I'll host, I'll host.
I'm going to leave the lobby, yeah.
Okay.
I'm not capable.
It's my first day.
i'm gonna say it is it says like what's it rent is due in three days oh that's that's very lethal okay you know how i found this game you know how i mean i found this game because there's like less than 70 reviews or some yeah i oh look i could join lime oh someone needs to invite nimi because we're not official friends no i can draw my exposed i'm in i'm in oh jesus okay you guys They're louding.
Oh my god, they're louding game.
Okay, I'm gonna mute everybody.
Goodbye.
It's just your fucking profile.
I'm here then.
Okay, I'm here too.
Oh god, have you got a weird name?
Oh, I know where you are.
I know what you are.
You're you.
did last night okay i just muted everybody in discord i muted everyone too like i just love how we're doing i just love that's just your wait i kind of love it though it's kind of funny
so silly so silly we know that they're not in yet okay they're snuffy they're snuffy low-res faces i don't know what i like i like your faces i'm here yeah yeah we're just waiting for it neem me yeah
snum it gets me every time because i always forget that's why i couldn't find her i was sleeping snuffy And it was like, no, there's nobody called Snuffy on your list.
What did you mean?
The shit doesn't run in the past 10 years.
Oh my God, we all just got like, how many other snoozes do you know?
What?
No, I just typed the name.
No, Michael, you want to be new.
Oh my gosh, this has a weird name.
The sensitivity is so high in this game.
It really is.
I have to turn everything so far down.
Yeah.
What's the, oh my gosh, I don't know.
Oh my God.
Now it's way too low.
Welcome to Snuffy.
Sloppies.
We have franchised into space.
I like the zoom.
I like zooming out on everybody's face.
What am I doing?
What are you doing?
One through seven.
Oh!
Here we go.
I love the duns.
It's very good.
Yay!
Sloppies in space.
I played the two of us that you know was actually on.
I can't tell either.
you're saluted we have to do oh my god you're dabbing you're dabbing stuffy what what's dab what button is dab five five we don't know because we can't be ourselves what am i doing saluting oh no wait wait what was that one what am i doing that is when my flexing what the did you just do i think that's seven i think it's kind of a flex but actually because there's not that much detail on the rings it kind of look like you just started to take a shit or something
all right we have to welcome me into the family welcome to the fast food experience with the slopies it's not stressful employee in the sloppy franchise no you're not intruding orientation you are very welcome look at her go look at her go look at her go are going to be working i think we just joined in yeah you're green yeah it's just random i'm pretty sure i think so i think it's random how do i how do i become a green i want to be green we just walked into the back we look like we're gonna like bloody mary bloody bloody bloody mary bloody
What just happened?
Guys, do not go into the mirror and say Bloody Mary, please.
Don't go into the bathroom at three.
Let's do it.
We'll watch from here.
Here, watch, watch, watch.
Bloody Mary, Bloody Mary, Bloody Mary.
Oh.
Voice activation betrays you again.
No!
Oh, hold on.
Bloody Mary.
What happened?
Maybe it's only once.
Why are you all over?
way over here.
That was so scary though.
You go, you do it.
Snoopy, try it again.
Yeah, this is stuffy.
You did it.
Okay, Bloody Mary, Bloody Mary.
And then I just turned around and there was like somebody in the hallway and they killed me.
Bloody Mary.
Oh, I don't know.
Do you think it was, do you think it was just a regular customer that came into the hallway?
It was my boss, he knew I was five times in the bathroom.
The devs hit the blow up command.
It's this one.
The boss was like, hey, hey, this is it.
Bloody Mary, bloody Mary, bloody Mary.
Maybe it's only once per game.
Yeah, maybe it's one.
Yeah, we gotta wait for day two.
Okay, so, take a new order for my customer.
Ah!
Who killed me?
How did I die?
Oh, you just can't sleep on your blood.
Oh, oh.
Oh.
Because my helmet is getting cracked, guys.
Oh, yeah, I broke my helmet.
Whoa, that's my body!
Are you dead?
Me's dead, we haven't even started the work day.
When can I die?
It's the easiest work day of my life.
You can't come back until the next day.
So, oh.
Okay.
over there and then i'll be okay yeah i'll spectate nimmy so that we could see her pov there's some there's like a fun ride down here you guys oh a fun ride she like stunned she like a like a shocked hamster no i'm dead oh wait no you know
oh my god my oh my head oh my god they're just they're just playing with me
Look at this shit.
We're just printing these out.
We've got to wash it.
Yeah, be careful, Liz.
This comes with the sloppy move.
Guys, I think Nimmy is not talking so much.
She might be nervous or shy.
We're kind of, we're kind of, where the sloppies are a little crazy.
Yeah, she's dead until the next day.
Doki, what is this?
Look at that.
Oh, look at these.
Whack it.
Oh, Doki just died.
I can...
Can you hear me, Doki?
Yeah, I can hear you.
Who would have thought...
If you whacked it, you ate my fat.
Maybe we're serving them spider burgers.
I whacked it and it fought back.
Oh, who would have thought it would do that?
I see.
Who would have thought it would self-defense?
like yeah that's crazy yeah it's insane how dare they fight back like you did not know who i am you should turn her into a burger okay you're gonna get thrown into the you're gonna get thrown into the meat grinder yeah we got we're running out of burger meat this is the easiest work day of our lives we haven't even started the work day it's just easier to carry
Okay, now we gotta see if we can actually put them on a burger.
Like, did you kill the spiders yet?
Because I have a gun.
No, we probably should still be watching.
Luffy carrying your head around.
I'm watching Nimmy carry your head around.
I feel like this game needed a tutorial, but we're just...
Yeah, I don't know what to do.
There's gotta be something we can do with it.
Luffy is the tutorial, but we're not paying attention.
There's a start the work day by using the switch.
There's a switch!
Oh, Jesus, it's coming down.
There's a lot of hiccups.
And we don't love these.
Do we have the order slips?
Oh my god, please, start the work, just start the work day, guys.
I like the Halloween decorations.
It's fun.
Oh, is there?
Okay.
Yeah, there's like pumpkins and stuff.
Don't lose your head, Doki.
No, they're just waiting.
They're too old.
Oh my god, they finally...
Oh, they can make us a freaking logo.
Snuffy, no!
She's distracted.
She's not distracted by it.
Oh my god.
Like, I'm going through the caves.
Like, I'm going to start the work day, and then she found the PC.
She can't help it, she's a V-Tuber.
I got this.
I'm gonna draw this.
Oh my god!
I just saw her.
Oh my god, she got me!
I just saw Lymu got me!
I don't think anybody's- Yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
Lymu's actually trying to work.
I upped overall volume for everyone.
You what?
I upped all the time.
Look!
I made burger meat!
He was like, make sure to up up meat and stuff me.
I was like, gotcha.
How is the audio for people, everybody?
I'm drawing.
Yeah, how is the audio, everyone?
I'm the social media guy.
Liebu!
Pull the- Do we want to start the day because they might revive them?
No, but wait, what about my picture though?
I need to- Oh, are you actually drawing?
Okay.
Yeah, yeah, no, I actually am.
No, wait.
It's gonna be good.
Start the day!
We're never gonna play this game because we're gonna be dead on it.
We're just like watch Friday.
You know what?
We are a watch party with Duck Roots right now.
Yeah.
This is our watch party.
Oh, I can mute, Doki.
Bye.
Everybody's at their max.
I think it's just also the...
I think it's up the overall volume and then we turn people down individually.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Okay, Limeo can turn on the fucking jukebox but not start the day.
Bloody Mary.
Oh, go Nimmy, go!
Oh, Mimi, dance.
This is our purgatory.
You know, get everyone nice and relaxed for their burgers.
I feel like I should be like, you know, free.
like I don't know just talking over this like hey girl this is this we are truly this is it this is where we're stuck forever I'm stuck watching fast food workers figure out how to fucking start the day just open the store you know for the burgers
Burgatory.
This is actual real fame.
We've got cup lids and cups.
And sheemes.
Just logo.
Sheemes.
They haven't even brought us up at all.
They completely have forgotten about.
Burgatory.
Yeah, we're in Burgatory.
Wait, I can't hear you anymore, Doki.
Do you guys see what the logo is?
Oh, now I can.
I just know.
Where, where, oh, no, I see it, I think.
Oh, I see the logo.
It's beautiful, though, right?
It's beautiful.
I'm gonna start the day.
She's starting the day.
No, that's the wrong button.
That's the wrong button.
There you go.
Progress the day further to close up early.
Are they back?
Thank you, guys.
We just, just end the day.
End the day.
Make the order and deliver it to a customer.
Wait, I think if they all...
Or we could just try and do it.
Because we're not going to do it very well.
There's a guy!
I'll just give it like a quick go, I guess.
They'll kill each other.
Let's see.
Start assembling a burger by placing a bottom bun.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, I don't think you're going to do that.
We're still watching.
Wait, which one's the burger?
There we go.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Finish by adding a top bun and pressing...
Oh, there's a guy!
Look how cute he is!
This is like...
Oh!
There's the customer.
back if you know what's good for you.
Why is he so rude?
I think every time you hit the bell, you're going to get a customer.
Hold on, what's your order?
This is our tutorial video, Mint.
We're literally watching tutorial video.
Oh, wait, I just...
Oh, my God!
She didn't say...
Why does he have anger issues?
You should let the customer service job be me.
You should be the customer.
Oh, do me!
You should stay back if you know what to do.
Hello, welcome to Burgatory.
Welcome to Burgatory, Nimi.
I'm going to take your order.
Thank you.
Thanks.
That was something.
I think the burger was interesting.
Then and I will be watching all three of you trying to start the day.
I fear my army.
Oh, here we go.
There's the reader.
One is three burgers and that's it.
But we just didn't have an orientation.
It's not our fault.
Our original manager didn't give us an orientation.
Oh.
Exactly.
Come on, Stuffy, you can do it.
It's not our fault.
There you go.
Is that guy still just walking around?
Oh, my God!
Yeah, it is.
I think he's just walking around till he gets his burger.
I'll be right back, my little ghost.
Okay.
All right.
Hi, Stuffy.
Welcome to Burgatory.
Yeah, welcome to Burgatory.
Can we take your order?
I thought you guys would come back to life when it started.
I'm sorry.
It's okay.
We're just chilling.
Yeah, no, we come back to life on the next day.
I think Lymu should just die though.
Die, Lymu.
Die.
Yeah, Lymu should just die.
There's no way she can...
She's gonna shoot the customer.
Do it.
Kill him.
She's getting too many customers!
There's a line!
Oh, you're right, you're right.
She's gotta weed them out.
She killed him!
Oh, my God.
She just killed a customer.
That's not very Snuffy up here.
What just happened?
Oh, she slipped.
She slipped on her, uh, she slipped on Snuffy's blood.
Hey, Snuffy, okay?
Guys?
Hello?
She's still taking order.
I haven't figured out how to make a burger, man.
Okay, Limu is our tutorial.
Yeah, this is our tutorial video.
What about the guy she killed, though?
Like, what do you do about him?
Yeah, what do you do about him?
You gotta make him a burger.
Still?
Wait, maybe she could use the customer to make more burger meat.
Oh, yeah.
Wait, but she got the meat from the bugs downstairs.
Okay, whatever.
Yeah, yeah.
Let's see.
So we have a box of birds.
Oh, my fucking nabby!
What did she slip off?
Can we figure out how to make a burger yet?
Yeah, she's still trying to figure it out.
She shot a custom room, but we don't talk about that.
She shot a custom room.
All right, let's see.
She's definitely the manager, then.
That's the respawn device.
Yeah, respawn.
I'm going to call her, but there's unruly custom rooms.
Oh, true, true, true.
Yeah, that's what we got.
It's like, I want to talk to your manager, and we said limo with a gun.
Wait, what's happening?
Oh, my God, you could have been like...
You destroyed our bodies, and we could have come back at any time.
um we're probably we're probably we're probably dead oh we're probably dead i haven't figured out how to open the burger box yet
don't be difficult get in the fucking tune oh it's the res the two look it's the res i think it might be a recharge maybe there's a rose yeah apparently we grinded your guys's body We'll never come back again.
We need to sell some burgers.
Oh, it costs money to revive.
Oh.
Yeah, yeah, I saw that.
I like how that one brought Mimi back and she's like, okay, figure out the burgers.
Oh, that's cute.
Oh, there's our orders up there.
I mean, I like how she basically revived Mimi just to delegate her fast just like real like hard time work i mean it's like it seems to be working so you know what actually i'm going to do that who's frying the the mate maybe wait oh maybe they're in here hold up what about in here oh we got a patty fridge
i wonder if they like a rage mechanic i mean i guess maybe i'm going back there to eat some Oh, yeah.
Okay, perfect.
Where's my burger?
Pickles.
How do you know when it's done?
You just, oh, okay.
It's turning around and seeing Nibby.
I think it changed color, right?
Yeah, it turned like less red.
All right.
Patty.
Patty cake, pat.
Oh.
Oh my God, I found the little beef.
Oh my God, that's so immersive.
I love it.
It is, it's so immersive.
Oh, really?
All right, so we need someone to do the fries.
I think me will be perfect for fries.
And then I can look at the food.
So where is it?
Shit, what number is it?
I want to take the other one.
It's fine.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
But it's going to be the front because it will be Squidward at the front.
They're leaving!
We could be Squidward.
It's right here, man.
What is going on with that man?
Yeah.
The guy that died yet.
He looks like he's like banging his hand on the floor.
Like he's like, oh damn it, I'm just not in a burger.
Nimmy's gonna put him in the blender.
Wait, is she?
She's putting him in the blender.
We were running out of meat.
She's gonna revive him.
No, I think she's blending him.
Yeah, I think he's blending him for more meat.
We're running out.
This is a good game.
Here you go.
Why did they just...
They should just throw themselves into the blender and then end the day.
Where do you get the meat from?
Oh, it comes from the right side.
Oh, I see it.
Here you go.
He was huge.
Oh, he gave two boxes.
Oh.
Actually, like, the cheat code.
Because we don't have to pay for more meat.
Oh, my God.
Yeah, but we need more customers.
We have to pay for the drugs.
Wait, no, I heard someone.
the hell where the fuck oh god this is awful yeah thank you we haven't figured out where you went into the place wait that makes so much sense put him in the grinder too yeah yeah exactly unlimited me wait how do you restock the meat oh you can't put it in the fridge unfortunately the words has gotten around that we suck and nobody's coming do we close the store our yelp for these The trimming is so pathetic.
It's so pathetic.
So sassy, yeah.
Okay, let's close up early.
Okay.
Oh my god!
Oh, we're here!
We walked in.
Finally.
Stuffy?
Wait!
Wait, Stuffy?
Wait, there's Stuffy right here!
There's a...
I guess we gotta put her in the grinder.
That's my second grinder.
I have your head here.
Gotta grind her up.
How do I throw?
There she goes.
Well, she's just made of bolts.
She's...
She'll be fine.
She's grinding.
What's this do?
I can't touch it.
Alright, guys.
Let's go.
I'm ready to serve!
We don't want a reputation for having frozen burgers.
Get to work, get to work!
I'm cooking up burgers!
Oh, hello!
New order number eight!
Oh, would we like to be the front of house, Minty?
Yeah, I'll be the front of house.
You like to promise not to put burgers in covers anymore?
Uh, no, I- I- I- There are no covers to put the burgers in.
And what the fuck is that?
Cheese?
Is that cheese?
That looks like cheese.
I mean, if it's yellow, it's...
Space cheese.
And some fries and a soda.
Yep.
New customer coming in.
Oh, I got you.
Hello.
Why don't you have small things?
Oh, two new customers.
Two new customers.
Let me see how they're feeling today.
How are you feeling?
Okay, he doesn't say anything.
How are you?
Oh, okay.
They're angry.
They're hungry!
They're hangry!
Oh, thank you.
Order number eight?
Order number eight.
Oh, he's coming, he's coming.
Ah!
I'm sorry.
Number nine is two burgers and some tomatoes.
I got the...
Did he pay for that, or...
Oh, we got Jason coming in.
Hello, hello?
Hey, what did he say?
I'm getting tired of your gawking, yeah.
Maybe he doesn't like to be looked at.
Wait, we have two number nines?
They will kill you if you don't listen to them.
Yeah, I know.
One guy punched me already.
I'm making order number 12.
Here you go, Mint.
Here's another order.
Number 12?
Number nine.
Wait, is this 10 or nine?
Wait, wait, I have the drink.
Did you get...
Oh, hold on.
Here you go.
Oh, oops.
Oh my god, did you do?
There's no drink for that one.
Number nine, number nine.
Is it number nine?
Blip-blop.
That's what he said.
He was happy.
Don't look at that guy.
No, he said it was fine!
He said it was fine!
Are they fighting already?
No?
No, everything's okay.
Oh, see, they'll punch you, they'll punch you down!
Are you okay?
Oh, we have dirty trays.
Where do we put this?
I wonder.
Oh, I put it here, maybe?
Oh, dirty tray.
Okay.
We gotta clean up.
In the grinder.
Where does it go?
Oh.
A sound.
Fossilade.
I'll take that.
This is order number...
Uh...
I didn't make any more patties.
What's the order number 10?
Order number 10!
Somebody over here.
Which one of you?
Order 10.
Thanks!
Just what I wanted!
Blip-lop, blip-lop!
He was satisfied 100% Oh really?
Yeah.
You baby!
Yeah!
Our side of fries.
Our rent is due tomorrow and we covered 14% of it.
Don't think...
We're at a 2% net gain for rent.
Thanks.
Maybe we can do it.
I got order number 11.
Where did he go?
He's over here.
All right.
Hello, sir.
Here's order number 11.
That's not what he wanted.
He is so...
What did you do?
It was the wrong order.
I can't pay minimum wage.
I like this thing.
Yeah, I wish dishes in real life were like this.
I wish we had dishes in real life.
At all.
Oh!
What happened to me?
Watch out!
I'm moving so slow.
What did I trip on?
We don't go close early.
Maybe someone will come in.
We'll get the rush.
Yeah, we're at 38%.
We're almost there.
Yeah.
We still have five minutes.
To attract customers.
Okay.
Yeah, oh, wait, Nimi, you can dance in front of the jukebox.
I said we could take out our own.
We're just in debt now, guys.
No worries.
Let's sweat.
But I'll fight.
I love working at Sloppies in Space, guys.
Oh my god, you guys were like sick.
That was actually kind of fire.
This is exactly what's going to cool in the crowd.
Yeah, that's what I'm saying.
Yeah, sure.
It's like those buskers that put like five dollars.
on a tray so you see like before why did I see someone orange just walk by in the kitchen what wait what did you see that wait who is that wait who is that do is it a dokey doppelganger doppelganger
I forgot that happens wait who is that guy oh it's a mimic yeah oh my god that was spooky well make him into pethys yeah make him into burgers yeah oh wait never mind we don't have a customer never met no nobody's here wait you've been like we've been able to make him work for us where did he come from though he was probably gonna rob us you guys come on yeah he had a suspicious smile i don't trust him yeah yeah i didn't trust him no questions asked i don't understand why doesn't anyone want to come eat at our restaurant we have such a good aesthetic here let's what's outside maybe like we've been decorated for halloween oh can't check
who's that lady looks like my grandma on her shoulder oh looks like she was bitten by like a werewolf
there's stuff over here even what's over here oh this is the bathrooms bloody Mary bloody Mary bloody Mary wait it's a new day we might be able to that's true there's still two minutes left though yeah maybe someone will come in like on the last minute and be like I would like five burgers and they'll yeah they'll tip us like a hundred dollars yeah they'll tip us for a good service in the in the middle yeah i like warped that's it oh that's not working for me just talker but burger yeah we'll
just put it here oh dang it i did it again sorry why do i keep slipping five minutes of the shift completely empty should we just close up for tomorrow no we can go kill rats downstairs yeah there's still rats downstairs there are still rats downstairs rat spiders made out of shadows Give me the rats problem where the health inspector comes in.
For what it's worth, you could only fire the shotgun once.
Can someone press number four?
Yeah, there was that light saber.
The rat sword.
I like that one.
Yeah, there was a light saber downstairs.
Oh, yeah, there was.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, we can just use that.
We can kill the rats in one minute.
Kill the rats, kill the rats, kill the rats.
Rots, rots, killing all the rats.
We are.
It's still in there.
I don't think anyone removed it.
This is for spanking the naughty customer.
Where are they?
Oh, there's one.
Yeah, there's one over there.
It's kind of cute.
Snoopy took the bat away.
Shoot him.
Nice.
Now use that.
Oh.
That was easy.
Yeah.
I will offer you up.
You will give us a chance.
abstinence.
We have 20 seconds left.
Patty box!
Wait, what happened to Snuffy?
Or is this the imposter?
Wait.
No, that's Snuffy right away.
Oh, that's Snuffy's old body.
Yeah, yeah, that's your old body.
Alright.
Zero.
I'm closing.
The day is over!
Okay.
How do I put these in there?
We have day old burgers ready to go.
Oh.
Wait, how do I put the patty in here?
We think it's full and it's not working yet.
You know it's full right now.
I have a lot of patties.
Wait, how do I?
Okay, drop it.
Okay.
What's that?
Thank you.
Nothing made me trip and it pissed him off.
He's not dead.
Oh no, he's not sitting down.
We need to blow him up!
Uh oh.
Wait, where's the gun?
His reach is insane!
Where's the gun?
Oh, okay.
I got him, I got him, I got him.
Good job.
Oh, we have customers!
Alright.
Let's get this.
This day started.
Two patties.
One tomato.
One triple.
Is someone working?
Me the bottom bud.
I'll work on order 14 if nobody is yet.
I'm doing fries.
I'm placing a bottom bun.
Two patties.
I'm two trips away from dying.
If you go to the healing chair, it does just heal you.
Wait, there's a healing chair.
There's a healing.
Oh.
I'm doing 13 right now.
Oh, wait, we got more people.
Okay, I'm doing 14.
One tomato.
Wait, where do we get tomato from?
Wait, is that pickle or is that tomato?
There's a spill.
I'm getting the clean and supply.
I'm going to do order 16.
I have all these cooked patties.
There's one on the floor, but it's okay.
Where do I get the tray from?
It's still good.
Are you guys here?
That's where you made the patties are.
Oh, I see.
Thank you.
I need fries on the floor.
Where is it coming from?
I need fries.
They're fries on the floor?
I'll take them.
Oh, whoops.
Okay, I'm delivering 13.
Is it you?
Delivering 16.
I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
Okay.
All right, we're fine.
10-second rule?
Yeah, that's fine.
Everything's good.
They ate it?
He'll never know it was on the floor.
It's saving space Three patties One cheese Oh Um What'd you make these out of I don't know They're truffle fries They're truffle fries Are you guys making 15 already?
No I'm not I'm just watching Rent is due today guys Lock in Lock in I got a coin.
What?
Someone left a coin.
I didn't know where to put it.
What do I do with it?
Where do you frame it?
Put it in the jukebox.
Oh, no, it's out of order.
Does it work?
No.
Is someone making the order?
Okay.
Lime.
Lime productive.
Who gets three burger, three patties, and one cheese?
delicious he's come with extra sloppy extra sloppy oh he is happy wait rent is due today and we're not making it yes we will we still have six minutes the rush order is coming in the rush order is coming in guys are you done with us sir oh okay my bad i do think if we didn't shoot the last customer line move we might have later that's true we've had to shoot somebody like every kill us what do you think that's preventable though yeah i think it was you know if someone didn't you know okay i'm in favor of shooting i'm just gonna say i'm in favor of shooting the shelf and make me trip next to him what happens when the rents do we don't pay i'm pretty sure we're gonna get lethal company and ejected into space probably yeah there's no way there's no way Why don't we have more customers?
What about this?
This very rare coin!
Wait, can I use it here?
Yeah, can you use it here?
Why is the lights freaking out?
Why are the lights freaking out?
I don't know.
Why do the lights turn off?
Wait, all they wanted to do was buy candy!
We spent all our money on fries.
Wait, why did we look...
Did you spend $200 on the machine?
Because our renters went down by like 20%.
What happens to our rent?
I might have spent money on fries.
I might have bought...
Oh.
I might have put the pride on Amazon.
Wait, do we need to go downstairs and turn the power back on?
I guess so, yeah.
I'll go do that next time.
There's not going to be anything there that will fucking jump me.
What's that sound?
Oh.
Wait, it's scary.
I ate...
Wait, do you guys...
I don't know if it's because I ate the candy, but you guys all sound really weird right now.
Wait, you ate the...
I was wondering where the candy went.
You ate the candy!
You guys, I think I'm having a really bad trip.
right now yeah you deserve for that karma candy i hate the candy i'm having a really bad trip right now this is not good karma hey
what do you see that what oh what is that do you see yeah why is it like that yeah why is it why is snuffy looking back at us i'll check it out
what happened did you did they turn did they turn it back on what the thought i would die i'm a very choked snuffy did you guys see that though wait i think it's just glitched because that was just really crazy timing wait what are you doing in there oh my god no wait you're making shit okay good okay so update i went to go fix the power and lauren was like what's up you know being like super cool oh what's happening oh i think we're about to die i don't know what happened but i don't know i don't know these
batteries okay okay
whoa why is all this happening and we still have no customers
thank god a little mini game There's like a rat!
There's rats in- Oh my god, what's going on?
Oh, I think she's having a bad trip.
I think- No, there's rats!
There's rats!
I just saw one.
They're stealing our food!
I can't believe the right thing says- Wait, oh my god, they're bad!
I'm gonna abuse- Oh shit.
Hold on!
Where's- where's a rat?
Give me a rat!
Oh, oops.
What just happened?
Alright, I'm gonna kill this rat.
I just slipped on something.
Where's a rat?
Give me a rat.
I'll kill a rat.
You want my rat?
You want to shoot him?
Yeah!
Oh, yeah!
Oh, wait, no!
Go make him into a patty!
That's a nice green rat.
It kind of looks like the jelly rat.
I like him.
He's cute.
I just want to hold him.
I keep him holding out my rat.
Nice rat.
Here, here.
Oh.
him.
Oh, this is out of ammo.
Steven, come back.
Wait, where'd he go?
When are we going to get more customers?
Grab the rat.
Grab that rat.
Oh my god, oh my god.
Wait, did I grab him?
Stop, stop, stop!
He's so slippery!
I'm putting these back.
I guess that's what...
We found out what happens when we leave a bunch of burgers around.
Yeah!
The space rats.
That makes sense.
Alien rats.
Duh!
Yeah, of course.
I think we gotta accept our fate.
I do.
I don't... I don't...
How do we keep losing money?
It's the fucking customer stop coming after about three minutes.
Right!
I think we gotta work fast, I'm pretty sure.
Yeah.
So we gotta have a healthy stream of customers.
Here we go.
Wait, what's salute?
Not that one.
I think sloppy court's gonna send in a representative and fire us.
Send, go fake.
Oh, you guys are, oh, here we go.
Oh.
Oh, why is he a capitalized?
Thanks you for your service.
Oh, random things are capitalized.
That's fine.
Brickbox Incorporated is eligible to initiate a self-destruct protocol installed upon the sign of the owner's code.
contract oh oh we just happened we're dying one at a time not it no no no not it not it no i'm safe i'm fine oh wait that's dokey's feelings use of company funds meant for the operating cost of the diamond not it not it suspicions of industrial espionage being conducted by a single employee working in the same establishment as you uses or isn't capable of paying for said services hampering with
this is funny i like the the individual death that was a narc i guess yeah
your diner you served 16 orders 67 percent of the lover orders were acceptable oh my god he suffered 10 casualties that seems about right yeah yeah But it says zero customers lost their lives.
So shooting that guy didn't count.
Yeah.
Uh, I think, do we get invited again?
Do we invite again?
But yeah, was the sound better now?
Oh, I think everybody still has everybody to zero.
La la la la la la la la la.
Oh!
There it is from LimeLicious.
Hello team!
Go save Bloody Mary at the window again.
Oh yeah, it's true, let's hear it.
I'm gonna watch him here.
We're going for Snuffy though.
You wanna do the honors, Nimmy?
Wait, I can't hear you.
Oh no.
Nimmy!
Oh wait, oh, I know what happened.
I gotta reset the lobby, hold on.
Oh, just kidding.
Reset?
Oh, there we go.
Oh, Snuffy had an issue with her invite too, so it's fine.
NIMMUTED!
I feel- I think I'm gonna make it- NIMMED still seems quiet to me, so I'm gonna lower everybody and then, like, turn the overall game up.
Oh, oopsie!
NIMMED, can you talk?
Can you hear me?
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah!
Yeah, we can hear you.
I can hear you.
Okay.
there we go hopefully enough people get in it should be at five now okay we wait i think we can do it this time i feel like i like the little random events that happen it makes the random events are cool yeah those are fun yeah oh we get them the mimic was the mimic the fact that you saw like though you were like there's an orange person walking back there it's so scary um if the mimic is like some like it's you it changes to a different person because like I saw I saw Mitt walking there and I was like where are you gonna stop oh that's Mitt oh Snuffy needs another invite oh yeah I got invited should be should we get there oh there she is welcome hello hello all right let's do that Bloody Mary thing oh yeah Mimi you do the honors you might guess what the watch is happening I don't know,
I didn't see what happened before.
I just got knocked off.
He keeps resetting your mic.
Wait, we heard him die after night or whatever.
No, no, no, they live.
They live.
We die from other means.
It keeps resetting your mic.
Yeah, from other means.
Yeah, we die.
Yeah, we can't even go back to the passenger car.
My sloppy, my sloppy employee.
Uh-oh.
Yes, okay.
No?
Okay.
Alright.
We're ready.
They're coming in.
And they're coming in!
New order on the clock!
What do we got?
Two burgs, a drink, and pickles.
I'll get the bun.
One bun.
I'm making fries.
No fries on this one.
Nope.
Yeah.
We don't cook too many patties this time.
Because we don't want the space rats to come in.
Okay.
Are you making the burger?
How do I do it?
Oh, one person should...
Oh, another order!
Okay, I'm gonna make the burger then.
I'll make one too.
Oh, just three old patties.
I'm making order number one.
Um, how do I make a patty?
Oh, you make them here.
There's some over here.
Oops.
Oh.
I got more patties.
I got a soda.
Shody.
Okay, one.
Two.
It was three?
Three.
There's someone waiting to have their order taken.
Oh, I'm coming.
Oh, you set the vibe for the customers.
Yeah.
Three?
I'm working on it.
I got it.
Are you doing two or three?
I was doing three.
Oh, wait, they're the same.
Almost.
I'm doing with three.
Okay, I'll do two then.
New logo.
Wait, we have a new logo.
Did you not say my logo?
Oh.
Number two.
Number two coming up.
Is it you?
I don't know what I can do to it.
What the?
You're welcome.
Support.
Morally, support.
Yeah.
I'm trying new logos.
I'm going to do ordering for four.
Okay, I'll do five.
B3.
All right.
Are you okay?
Wait, snap me.
We need more patties.
Can you go kill an ant for us?
Or kill customers?
Either word.
Kill customers or kill ants.
Wait, I gotta pick up these orders too.
Yeah, yeah, pick it up.
I'm flipping that.
You mean our patties really?
We're already out?
There's no way.
I'm doing five.
There's two freezer pools worth.
What do you mean?
No, I don't need five.
Which one is five?
Who's five?
Are you five?
Okay, no, not my problem.
Number five.
Number five?
Oh, gosh.
Can I get close to you?
Flip-flop, flip-flop.
I'm already feeling the pressure, guys.
I'm going to crack.
Why does that music sound like a...
Urbanic theme?
Is someone doing order number six?
I'll get us the pop pull-up.
six i'll do six then okay i'll do seven i'll do eight okay yay team we're coordinating we're coordinating all right i got the soda this is the comic soda for which one um the black one but let's try please here's some more fries okay and uh seven is Uh oh.
Seven.
No!
It's okay!
We're already 50%.
Seven.
Woohoo!
Order eight.
I wish I could run faster.
I'm doing order nine.
Okay, I'll do order ten.
But someone get the cola.
I got the cola.
Alright.
More patties.
Order up.
Oh, I have to do it the whole time.
We're doing it!
One patty.
And the cheese.
We're gonna make so many people happy.
Uh, no, we're not.
Sophie!
Sloppy.
Oh, our logo changed once again.
Okay, number 10.
Number 10.
Our social media manager made a new logo.
Who are you?
10.
Ow!
I'm sorry!
Wait, what do I- Are you okay?
That guy was out of line.
He was out of this world, honestly.
Look, you matter, okay?
Like, even though we're fast food workers, we matter.
I know, they just, these people have never worked a service job in their lives.
I know!
They just don't know how to treat anybody.
Yeah, they think just because we're in service that we are lesser than them, that's so fucked up.
It really is, man.
Yeah, I think we have to make a much faster work with these patties.
I wonder if we're going to make sure to get in there.
We're going to take a bunch of patties now.
No, no, no.
Who cooked all these patties here?
Uh-oh.
Somebody's in trouble.
The rats are coming.
It's okay.
I'm hearing squeaks in the walls.
Put them back in the freezer.
Dispose of them.
No, wait.
Don't dispose of them.
Yeah, we're back there.
it starts with rats and then grown men start coming into the kitchens and maybe maybe they start coming on the third day yeah yeah they show up on the third day customers don't know it won't hurt them is it bad to just call it like i feel like we're only at risk of like weird shenanigans happening uh we need to like wait a minute oh yeah we can find a burger meat we're still here Oh yeah,
we do.
Yeah, we need to restock.
Yeah.
Oh, and no, one time the mirror was showing, like, Snuffy just standing there.
Go Snuffy.
It's a mirror.
I have nothing to attack with.
I'm just here for moral support.
Yeah.
Okay, one down.
I'll kill it.
I'll get it.
I'll grab it.
Do you think they come back?
Did she die?
Oh, you good?
No, I'm okay, I'm okay.
Oh my god, do you take full damage?
No, no, I thought he was also dead.
I thought you got a double kill.
Is there any more?
Did we get more?
Oh!
It
took the weapons.
It did?
No.
Oh.
It didn't.
Wait, does it cost money?
Is someone talking?
But the rats, they're gonna love cold.
I'm gonna go kill more more ants.
There was just one other.
I can get him.
I'm a winner.
Oh my gosh.
Where did that come from?
Buns from the heaven.
Buns from the heaven!
That's where all buns come from.
True.
Revenge!
Is best served.
Oh, there's more.
Okay.
That should be good, I think.
Yeah.
You got some more patties?
Yeah, can you grab the ants that I just killed?
Buns are from the heaven.
This way.
Hey.
Hi.
Nice shots, thank you.
What was that sound?
Did we get emails?
Bung Dippo!
Oh, we can buy stuff here.
The bank.
I hear rats!
I heard rats.
I heard squeaks.
I really did.
Are you okay?
There was no rats.
I heard.
What do the rats tell you?
No, they squeaked.
You can hear them in the walls.
I can't.
I can hear them in the walls.
They're in the walls.
They said we should wear these glasses.
We are the rats.
Our statistics.
They're watching you, Mitt.
They're watching you.
Look, what are you doing on the wall?
the pc nothing suspicious okay and this is just backing up oh true oh good boss would let us close early if we're so slow i'm just saying that's true yeah yeah that's just more money to pay the employees yeah exactly all right no i gotta spend all that money on right oh here they come Where do they come?
Good day!
I love working at sloppies in space.
The patty with two tomatoes.
Order 11.
I got him.
I don't got him.
Patty with two tomatoes.
Did you got him?
Yeah, I got him.
Is that really it?
Yeah.
So far.
Yeah, that's all he wants.
He knows what he wants.
He's an alien who knows what he wants.
Order number 12.
Come here every day.
Little little leap.
Woohoo!
Alien Mario.
There's so many patties.
We're getting two patties.
We get like two customers for days lettuce and pickle i'm gonna work on order number 13.
i'm doing 12.
wait what's that sound what was that what was that um she's okay right oh she exploded don't know why don't know why she exploded anyway yep working all in a day's work 12.
I'm getting 12.
Wait, we have no one at...
Blip-lop, blip-lop, blip-lop.
Okay, I made you have enough money.
Orange is 13.
Can someone take the orange?
Ah, sorry.
He's yelling at me.
What?
I don't even know what actually...
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Guys, this is really bad.
No, shit out.
Are you okay?
What's happening?
She resmed me.
She resmed me and she exploded, bro.
gotten for some reason something's killing us i don't i'm not even paying attention to anything i'm just doing my job fair enough i won't die they can't kill me i'm working on order 14.
wait was this pickles possessing people just i don't know let's all look up Stay mentally well.
Lettuce.
You know, call off today.
Oh dear.
Someone get the gun!
Wait, there's something grabbing me from the...
Grab me from the ceiling!
You can dodge him, right?
Okay, I got it.
Wait, I think someone else is dying.
Oh.
Who brought me back?
I want my picture in there.
There's a sword in them.
The gun!
Ah!
I got it.
Yeah, fuck him.
Oh, I made it.
I lived!
Okay, be careful of right here.
Oh.
I'm gonna grab Nimi.
I'm grabbing you, Nimi.
Oh.
I got you.
I'm gonna...
I will fix you.
A rap.
I'll fix you.
Wait, did he leave?
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
She made it.
Oh, you saved me.
Yeah!
Oh, gosh.
There's a bunch of guys coming in.
No.
I don't know what you can do with this in depth.
Two patties.
Oh, my God.
Wait, we have crazy number of orders.
Lettuce.
Oh, who's working?
I'm doing number 20.
I'm doing 15.
I got 15.
Can someone serve 15 right here?
Yeah, yeah, I got you.
I have the burger.
the fries wait wait the fries the fries put the fries in the bag i'm doing 20.
okay i'm serving 15.
oh no they're leaving oh no they're leaving wait we're packed house right now 15.
oh sorry
what are you saying to them what can i do i'm doing 17 17 coming out 17 coming out I'll serve 17.
Oh, you guys 17?
Okay.
All right, I'll do 19.
All right.
I'm doing 21.
I'm flipping what burgers.
I'm doing 19.
Three and cheese.
What was that?
There's something in the beds.
Oh my gosh.
We just have it so difficult.
I just want to be a little fast food person.
Oh, we have no fries.
Oh, I got fries.
Just kidding.
All right, I'm making more patties.
We need more fries.
I'm sorry.
Uh-oh.
Um.
You're welcome.
He's right at the counter!
Oh.
Yeah, you got him.
Good job.
What?
Did you get those odors?
I'm mopping.
Someone needs to take the odors.
I'll get the odors.
I'll get the...
Okay, I'll go...
I'll go...
Oh, ouch!
Sorry, I'm cleaning up.
I'm cleaning up.
Sorry, boss.
I'm the boss?
Wow.
We're fucking in the business.
We dreamed of dying.
We're finally getting it.
I know!
Wait, but we still have, like, quite a bit.
Okay.
What are you working on, Nimmy?
I'm making 22.
Okay, I'll make 23.
Wait, this is 22.
Lettuce 2.
What was that?
What up?
Jeez.
Where are we at?
Do we guys need any help?
Yeah.
You want to do 24?
From now on, I'm...
24, okay.
Yeah.
I've never made a burger before.
Hey guys, there's a link in the ceiling of their healing room.
I don't know what that is.
that means but there is oh it means it means half life don't walk that's what killed me oh i love half life yeah oh no i'm doing 24.
wait am i oh wait i'm doing 23.
oh wait i'm doing 23.
sorry i'm doing 22.
um basic kitchen 101 do not walk under the fence what are you doing i warned you Oh, I'm doing 23.
I'm doing 23?
Okay, I'm gonna do 20...
26.
Sorry.
Being safe.
Okay, I'm doing 24 then.
Okay, 23.
Blip-blop, blip-blop.
Whoa, who's dripping over here?
Who's making a mess of our establishment?
Starting to get hungry.
Oh, well, I'm starting to get frustrated at this mess.
Is the vent monster?
It drifts in everywhere?
I hear him.
I hear him wandering.
There's a guy getting angry out here.
Uh-oh, they're starting to leave.
Oh, no!
What was that?
I got the back.
That monster, I think.
Oh, you did?
Maybe, well, I don't know.
It's still leaking, but I shot it.
I think one of their customers exploded.
I don't know what happened.
It's okay.
I'm cleaning up after him.
I'll clean up, too.
Did anyone make you want to clean up?
We're cleaning up.
You're doing 27?
Okay.
He just leaked a little.
It's okay.
Here.
I got fries here.
nobody else's you can't go for it two patties two lettuce for 26 uh two lettuce two patty two lettuce i got the prize right here yeah yeah he liked it he liked it orange soda he liked it he liked it just don't mind me i'm grabbing a tray we got 20 seconds go go go quick quick quick He's about to leave,
he's getting ready to leave.
Seven, six.
You will, you will, you will!
Clutch, clutch, clutch, clutch, clutch, clutch, clutch.
We just wanted to look- Yeah!
He gave us two bones!
Oh my gosh.
Why did he look like- Would you like a dancer too?
Here you go.
I'm gonna buy some candy.
Yeah.
Wait, why did it laugh evilly?
Wait, it's not me that I'm just blowing people up.
If there's a monster in the vent, you had to, like, look for the goo drops and then shoot the vent that it was in.
Oh.
Oh, I said that.
I said, like, a million times don't walk under the vents because there's Half-Life 1.
My candy was yummy.
Wait, what the fuck?
What in the fuck did that eat?
I don't know.
Skill issue.
I gotta spend some of our money on ordering food because we're basically out.
Oh, what a busy day.
We got the day already?
Oh, it is close.
Are you guys ready to start the day?
No, no, no, no, no.
Order new stuff first?
Yeah, we should restock.
Wait, I'll make more soda.
Oh, wait.
The soda machine stops, too.
Wait, what do we need, love?
The soda machine out, too?
No, no, no.
It stops when the day is closed.
Oh, so we just have a half soda yet?
It's hard on hearing.
Oh, no, never mind.
I'm good.
Okay, we need more pickles and lettuce.
Well, we can order those online.
I'll order pickles and lettuce.
I've ordered the ingredients.
downstairs oh downstairs okay i'll go grab our stuff we might be with patty you can oh wow there's lots of stuff down here all right buns from the heaven yippee yippee actually i don't know what i grabbed flat soda that's the only way i can drink it oh is that is that the freezer i don't know what this is actually oh pickles i refilled lettuce yeah pickles here there we go
I'll go, I'm getting stuff too.
I don't think they can hear me.
Have I had flash soda?
Oh.
Are you okay?
There's a dead rat down there.
Oh!
Somebody can go get it.
I'll go get it.
Where?
Oh, there's no dead rat.
I thought I heard something in the...
I thought I heard something in the tunnels.
But I didn't see what you shot.
No, I didn't see it.
He was all the way back.
Oh, maybe that's why.
Right here.
Oh, you're so brave.
Wait, I can't grab him.
Maybe it wasn't a rat.
I can't grab him.
He's too far in there.
Oh, I thought we were going to be able to explore the caves.
Oh.
Oh well.
They'll respawn.
It's food for themselves.
Cannibalism.
That's true for the ecosystem.
Yeah.
Too deep in the hole.
Ah.
Man.
Get to work is what it says.
Scary.
Oh.
Does it cost money to heal yourself?
Not to heal, but to revive, yes.
Oh, okay.
So make sure you heal.
I'm healing.
Hi!
Good morning, team!
We got this team!
All right, everybody, rise and shine.
Let's go clock in.
Yeah.
Clock in, clock in, clock in.
All right, who's working on the first one?
I'm working on it.
Could you make me a blue soda, please?
Yes, I can.
Thank you.
Oh.
The grub soda.
Okay.
Two soda, one patty, three legs.
She'd be grubbing.
Grub soda.
Oh, is this Rob?
I need to tell you.
There's a grub soda right there for you.
Friendly reminder to check your events before you walk under them, guys.
Thank you.
Order 28 going out.
For the first hazard.
Let's do 29.
I'll get the soda.
Wait, what is that?
Alright.
Should I do 30?
Is anybody working on 30?
Nobody's working on 30 yet.
You go for it.
I got 30.
We're running out of patties again.
So someone needs to shoot the rat.
I'm making sodas.
Check the vents.
Oh, ha ha.
Oh, my gosh.
This guy's gooing all over the place.
We should have left the goo man.
Oh, gross.
Sterminated all of them.
Wait.
Oh, my God.
He's gooing.
Yeah, I'm going to give him day old soda.
He's not going to tell.
He doesn't know.
He doesn't know what.
know won't hurt him it was like mostly new anyway all right three sodas for all the orders oh nice thank you yep is anyone making 31 i got 30 i'm going out nope i think you're good to make here i'll start with uh i'll start putting the things on the trays one patty one lettuce one 31.
I'll get the fries for you, too, Nimi.
There you go.
I already got the sodas.
I made the sodas.
Oh, you did?
Yeah.
I made an extra soda.
It's for 31.
Yeah, that's for 31.
This guy's ready to eat in an order.
All right, I'm going to do 32.
All right.
I'll tell you what's 32.
It's three patties, one lettuce.
I'll do 33.
I think I hear something in the van.
you guys I love sloppies I love working at sloppies the benefits are great I'll never die here I'll never die exactly oh gosh we have so many orders okay who's working on what there's something in the vents again it's in the vents what there's something's wrong and I think they just assassinated somebody what
yeah this is me I'm me I'm me ah this is fake Doki fake Doki over here over here fake Doki fake Doki oh oh there he is there thanks oh wait who's that who's that um what What order are people working on?
Which burger is this?
I think it's 33.
I just did 33.
Wait, what about 29?
Someone do 29, please.
Okay, I'll do 29.
It's one patty, one lettuce, and one tomato.
One patty.
One patty, one lettuce, one tomato.
Oh, uh oh.
What's happening?
Oh, no.
One patty.
No, not remove.
I thought I grabbed it.
patties one patty i'm still doing it i'm still working on the greatest worker ever one patty one lettuce one tomato oh i'm fine fresh meat up fresh meat up fresh meat up 34 is three patties one pickle is someone doing 34 shall i i think you're doing it i'm thinking patty okay oh 29 is about to be over oh no wait oh gosh Do you want to give me a drink?
I'll do it.
I'll do it, I guess.
Remember, don't walk under the vents.
Double check the vents.
Okay, uh, 34 is covered.
Yeah, 35 is covered.
I'm doing I'm doing 37.
Who's doing 37?
Oh no, oh no, no.
Oh shit, okay.
Just keep working.
Oh wait, we can't.
We don't know what the order is.
I don't know if I...
Oh, we made it back.
Okay, we're good.
I'll do 36.
I want to do 35.
I got 35.
I'm on 36.
I'm going to do 38 then.
37 is one burger when she's two pickles.
La la la.
36.
That's it.
Which one is done?
36, 36, 36?
Where are you?
37?
Ah!
Oh gosh.
I just made that.
I just made that!
Oh
the charge!
36!
I can't run any faster!
Wait, where is he?
Did I miss it?
Wait, where's 36?
Am I blind?
Was the 36 the guy that...
I think 36 was the guy that knocked over my tray.
There's a rat!
Yeah, 36 freaked out and left.
Oh my god, that's double my people that have freaked out.
The rats are back.
We've covered rent, everybody!
We don't even have to worry.
Oh!
Who is that?
I went blue and walking around really slow.
That's me!
And I'm hurt!
That's why!
I'm old!
I almost died.
I almost died for real.
Sheesh.
That's suspicious.
Oh my gosh, wait, can I watch them?
Is this alive?
Oh no, it's not live.
Ow!
Oh my god.
Uh oh.
We got last.
Why me again?
That was 39.
I couldn't read it.
Oh my god.
He got me twice.
Okay, back into the healing tube.
Why did he?
He bee-lined towards me.
I'm so obsessed.
Oh god.
We're fine.
Rent is fine.
What was that?
Get out of here.
Oh.
Why do we have a dead guy here?
What?
There's a dead customer here for some reason.
Wait, how did he die?
I don't know.
Into the grinder.
into the grinder to be made into potty meat the lish throw a customer into the meat grinder what is this buns
I'm finally finished red I'm not I can't run oh the mob is outside oh by the way
Oh wait!
We suffered from success that long.
I'm going to grind here so I can respawn for the next day.
Because I'm once the bad crippling.
Just heal yourself!
What is she doing?
Telling us all to die so that she can heal herself?
What?
Yeah, we killed Jason Voorhees.
Oh, it took ten dollars!
It took ten dollars!
No, no, no, no, no, no.
That was already done.
Wait, but you guys could have used my body for more patties, so we didn't have to pay for patties.
No, the people don't make patties.
Yeah, we are robots.
Aww.
Yeah.
Are we doing lettuce wraps?
Oh, we got buns.
Wait, what?
Yeah, we got buns.
We got buns, huh?
We don't have to do gluten-free lettuce wrap burgers.
Are you okay?
Gluten-free in space.
I'm sorry to tell you that.
I'm trying to paint like the most pristine pictures.
It's all gluing and it's green.
What's our logo now?
Is it still the same?
I think it's the same because we started on the same day.
Becca sloppy.
This looks good.
Oh, come to sloppy.
Are you ready to start the next date?
Yeah, I think so.
Are you ready?
Alright, get to it.
Where's Lymu?
I was grabbing ingredients.
Oh, okay.
I flipped the boat.
Oh, we have refilled the tomato.
And the patties.
I shall buy cheese with our first product.
Oh yeah, where's our customers?
Um, he's sitting there, he's just invisible.
Oh, okay.
I have a cook patty for you.
I'll start- oh, there are fries in the making.
Um, well, you gotta be fucking patient.
I am patient.
Next order?
Alright.
Oh, that one.
Oh!
uh-oh could someone get I'm
a failed I'm afraid I failed what happened stuffy what happened oh my god I'm so sorry I don't know I shot him and he killed us both oh wait he's gonna kill everybody why is Nemi even I don't
know.
Um, we're fine.
Everything's okay.
What was that?
You're still taking orders?
Don't you want to make money so we can free Lymu back.
Only Lymu though.
Only Lymu.
Oh, I can't see.
Wait.
They've had me.
I can um give prize out of the frame.
Like everything will be fine.
Everything will be fine.
Okay, that's all.
I can read to you.
What do you need for now?
Wait, where's the trick?
The gun.
She's still alive.
The music is still so scary.
I can't read.
What?
What is Doki yelling about?
I can't understand her.
I can't hear.
I don't know.
The first one.
This is 49.
Where's 49?
Wait, where's 49?
Mimi's like Blair Witching.
What's going on?
I don't know.
She's just emoting.
I think the game is bugged for her.
Oh.
Wait, I can't hear Lymu.
Uh, Doki just died?
Oh.
Hi, Mid.
I didn't realize that you were in death's chat.
It's just Mimi and she can't move.
Oh yeah!
I'm free, I'm free from being stuck at least.
That was going so good.
We were doing so...
We did a good job.
You want to run it back one more time?
Yeah, we can try one more time.
Yeah, yeah.
Wait, how did you two die?
I got killed by the fucker that's sprinting around in the doorway just there.
Yeah, I know how you died last, but what about men and stuffy?
I tried shooting him, but he just killed me anyway.
I think.
Yeah, he just killed me.
Watch Snuffy try to shoot him and maybe miss.
And then he killed us both.
Oh, I see, I see.
Alright, restarting the lobby.
That thing's freaky.
I like the music that starts playing.
When all hell breaks loose, it's like...
We failed that shift because Snuffy failed us, everybody.
That's just the hard fact.
that's why we failed
you can never tell with this game
okay guys i have a bat just in case you have a bat oh b okay you can trip over on the bat just as i What should I make?
Oh wow.
That is worse.
That's not very convenient.
All right.
That's good.
Just in case.
Are we all ready to start our day?
Yep.
All right.
Because I don't think we need Mint anyway, because she's doing our social media right now.
Birthday's calm anyway.
She's like the Wendy's of our restaurant.
I'm gonna do one, two burgers, one pickle.
Oh no!
Victor to put a smiley face.
Catch a smiley face when it's done.
I wish I could make it... Oh, I can make it smaller.
Wait, I'm redo, redo.
Oh, there we go.
Okay, nice.
All right, order one, order one, order one.
Patty is getting ready.
No.
We'll make it...
Blonde.
This is my girlfriend.
Like fries.
Actually, I don't want it blind.
Let's stick to a simple palette.
Because our place of establishment is for the refined palette.
We don't need all of the fancies.
I think you know what to do.
These guys are actually terrifying, honestly.
All right, uh, okay, I'm making an order number five and not someone else does.
I don't think anyone's making five.
I see me making soda.
I'm making soda.
Sloppy.
What does apply to face mean?
I'm gonna get more patties.
I'm gonna do a rough, uh, do a hard job.
How do I get out of here?
Uh,
that's what it means on the face.
I'm our own mascot.
What's going on over here?
Wait, let me see.
Oh!
I tripped all the fucking train and oh my god.
Good.
Thank you.
Looks friendly.
It's fucked, it's fucked.
Somebody glooped, somebody glooped all over, watch out, spill, spill zone.
Thank you.
What are we working on?
I'm making number seven.
Okay, I'll make five.
Oh, these three birds and fries.
No, I'm doing five, I'm doing five, I have to remake it.
Okay, I'm doing eight.
Thank you.
So bad news, I shot a rat and the rat's body went flying, so like I couldn't get it.
What orders are being worked on?
What should I start on?
I'm working.
What do we got?
Five, seven.
Maybe we might need more prizes.
I'm doing five.
Anybody doing five?
There is no five.
I'm doing eight.
That's fine.
We're doing so good.
I'm going to order nine five.
There is no five.
Anybody got order nine?
I'm going to do it.
No, no, no.
Order nine.
Okay, snap me on nine.
I'll do ten.
All right.
I'm getting us more packed.
We're cooking today.
How's it still raw?
Our hands touched on the patties.
Oh my god.
Both reached for a title at the same time.
Both reached for the patty.
I need an orange soda pop.
Oh, is that?
Oh.
I gave it the soda, but it's already got a drink.
It's glued down now.
Off to eight.
Number eight.
Raise your hand.
Woohoo!
You're welcome.
Number five.
I don't know where am I in my life.
A little bit of...
And I'm on the side.
We need more...
I think we... I think we're fine with the...
Oh, this is like a patty that's raw forever.
A patty that's raw.
Wait, wait, what's happened to the computer monitor?
What?
Wait, no readers.
No wonder.
I think we're done.
That's it?
We're done?
We made our rent already, by the way.
I'm just gonna pay it.
And then we'll find money and then like pay like stockpile it for the next couple days.
Well that is if anybody else comes home.
I mean here, sorry.
Wait, can y'all look at you real?
What the?
What?
Yeah.
I'm worried about Mint.
Me too.
What's wrong with me?
I think she should get her some help.
I think she might have a rough home life.
What are you talking about?
What are we saying?
No, no, no.
No, Mint, we're here for you.
We're- What are you talking about?
I'm the company mascot.
That doesn't mean you can't have feelings, Mint.
It's okay.
Yeah, yeah.
We're all here for you.
It's okay to express yourself.
Exactly.
what's wrong what's why why are you guys bullying my appearance you might need to look in the mirror i think i think you might have tripped some some time ago i did yeah i think i think you should look in the mirror this is how i woke up
do you think we have insurance from this job You think we have...
Doesn't
have anything to do with Bloody Mary.
There are two cases of party downstairs.
Oh, nice.
Wait, who turned into a smiley face?
Yeah.
That's me.
I wanted to offset the vibe, so I'm...
I love the employee.
Wait!
I would be the good about today.
Wait.
Yeah, you could just make your own face.
What the hell?
Oh, I did it.
This is so sad.
Oh, what are you?
What's gonna happen?
Wait, look at me, look at me?
Is it just a blank?
It's just a void, right?
Is it just a void?
Yeah!
Wait, oh, here.
I'm gonna think of something.
Oh, wait.
I thought Nimi was still here.
I want to become, I want to become something else.
Hmm, guys, let's think.
If I could rebrand into anything that I ever wanted, what would I ever want to be?
What would you want to be?
That's a good question.
Yeah.
Nimi, you can try.
Oh, yeah, yeah, Nimi, you should change your, you should get plastic surgery.
Yeah.
We all did.
Hey, hey.
Oh, we all did.
Oh, I know.
Yeah, I'll go after.
What the fuck?
God, you're so scared.
no key you look like a mimic like you that's how you're gonna you're gonna get sloppies no now i'm gonna have to like i'm gonna accidentally shoot one of you because i don't know your things anymore i'm smiley she knows where she gets sloppies tell us how much you love sloppies oh no i messed up there's an undo there's an undo so much that i spend every day of my
You can redo, you can redo.
I can redo it, yeah.
Oh my god, I love how it's on the walls, it's skin.
Yeah, I see like mint logo.
It's sloppy.
Yeah, is that sloppy in fireworks?
How she feels every day working at sloppies.
Look how happy she is.
Look, she's smiling.
Smiling.
We're smiley.
I was just chilling.
Oh, look at this.
Oh, beautiful.
Okay.
What is it?
I wonder what Lymo's gonna make.
All right, how do you feel working at Snappies every day?
What was that?
Didn't anybody hear like a scary voice?
piano no no i think that's just disco alien disco music yeah we only have one track in our jukebox yeah it says it's broken disco this is an absolute classic you guys if you don't with alien disco then like yeah what do you love about alien disco smiley i love that it plays non-stop
Oh, make all the orders 100% correct in a single day.
Yeah, we did.
But we can stock our money for the other days.
Yeah, I think we should.
I think we should, yeah.
We can buy weapons.
Wait, we can.
Oh, yeah, we can buy more bats.
Lightsabers.
Whoa.
What was that?
Oh, she was bloody marrying.
Sorry, I was- I was- I was having a smoke break in the bathroom.
Do you get a thrill from that?
Is it like a bloody high?
Your bloody high?
It was by GF.
She just dropped out my- Oh shit!
Your girlfriend?
Wait!
Wait, she said yes?
No, we're not at that level yet, but she just doesn't know it.
Oh, that's- Oh, I mean, you guys- killer smile you'll get her you'll get her yeah she says she says that i have a dead-end job at like sloppies yeah but you're gonna you're up for that promotion though aren't you
she's alive i'm alive she's feeling sally yes tree i love i love your face it's so good yeah don't you just have a face don't get you have you ever seen don't you did not you're just face but we use black on black oh you look you look like the fucking hey who turned out the lights thing and dr who actually that's a fucking great idea hold on hold on oh no you need to do like a black background and then a skull have you ever watched dr people for i watched the one with david tenet and then he recreated and i was like not my doctor pretty much don't there Do they always do that?
Doesn't that probably do the doctors?
That is how doctors work, yeah.
Okay.
Yeah, but that was my line.
I was like, not my doctor.
Get out of here.
I think there was at least one or two that were like notable, right?
How many doctors?
11?
No, there's 15 or something now.
Yeah, there's 15 already.
Is David Tennant the one with the Fez?
Or do they all have the things?
No, that's, that's, that's, uh, he's the one where you see him probably crying That's Matt Is it Matt Smith?
It's Matt Smith.
He's in Game of Thrones.
David Tennant's the one that everyone obsesses over and he came back more than once.
Oh, yeah.
He's the one that sang the walking song.
I forgot his collar.
Look, did you see when he came back?
Five hundred miles.
Yeah.
And I will walk a hundred miles and I will walk a hundred more.
I forgot.
That's already, that's a different company's song.
That's, You did this though.
Yeah.
Oh, we're only like...
What was that?
That's your door bump.
It took a bump out of you because you're so irresistible.
I love that.
That's very good.
I changed.
Oh, it's your eye patch.
That's my eye patch.
Hey, don't make...
You got it.
Get it right, mom.
Get it right.
It's my eye patch.
It looks so stupid.
Wait, you can't tell it's an eye patch at all.
It really looks like...
Someone took a chop out of my face.
Where's the...
Oh, hello.
Welcome to Sloppy's.
I like your business.
I like your table touching.
You're doing good.
Oh, there's someone coming in.
There's someone coming in.
Why are they so, like, wiggly?
Look normal.
We're fine.
Everything's fine.
She may have put too many patties on the grill.
Order Order 22.
I was doing 22.
I got 22.
That's a lot of burgers.
22.
I don't know about you.
Oh my gosh.
Prize for 22 coming up.
Gonna make a home.
Oh no drinks.
No drinks.
Is anyone listening to the new Taylor Swift songs?
No.
I heard it's bad because she's happy.
Because she's happy?
Is that what you said?
Yeah, because like, yeah, because before his date.
Oh, it's because she's happy.
Now it's happening, like, happily, to be happily married.
So we saw her.
I'm doing Order 13.
Did someone make me the drink from 13?
I got you.
Thank you.
Good.
Thanks, pal.
You're so welcome.
Give a little extra fan service.
Thank you very much.
This job is easy.
Oh, we got more customers.
Oh, I'm not looking at you anyway.
Wait, wait.
I will see you on a bomb!
Oh.
Oh my god.
It's not even that scary.
Oh!
Ah!
How did I die?
This is my redemption arc, you guys!
I was just standing here!
Where'd you go?
Hold up, hold up.
You got this, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, hold up.
We need black.
Oh dear, we need black.
I think I clicked up and misclicked.
I think he's mine too.
Ow.
We died, Nimi.
Must have misclicked an ingredient.
Oh, he's...
I don't even know what happened.
He's probably lying.
Oh, he's like indestructible or something.
It seems bad.
It seems pretty bad.
Wait.
What?
I'm not alive.
How the fuck did you give me?
How did he, I don't, he got me too, I don't know how.
Wait, he just, he just snagged me from across the fucking room.
I just stubbed my toe every time.
Oh, Demi, congratulations.
Don't lie.
Oh, yeah, he's, uh, okay, me, okay.
Is he still out there?
Yes, he's still out there.
Oh, no.
Oh, you were so close.
Uh-oh, wait, my game broke!
My game broke!
Oh, there's the first!
Wait!
Because Snuffy!
Snuffy broke the game!
I thought, like, yeah, I saw him.
Have you seen me?
Do you want me to reset it?
No, this is kind of...
I don't know if he...
Wait, oh, he...
I'm... I'm alive!
We got a tufer!
Okay, let's get a lot.
Oh.
My bad.
Did he leave?
I think he might still be sneaking around.
Yeah, he's still out there.
He's still out there.
I don't think we can kill him.
Hey, is that why you never shot him?
Wait.
What the heck is that?
Wait, there's like also a...
He's gone.
He's actually dead.
He's gone?
He's dead.
Oh, dang it.
I did it again.
Hold on, I got you.
I got you.
Wait, you guys, I saw like a TV monitor or something going off.
We probably lost a lot of customers.
Lime moon.
Oh, dang it!
I don't know why he wiped this out.
Oh, wait, what?
There's another one.
Where's the mob?
Charge.
I'm healing?
I can't see where I'm looking at oh oh wait no you should oh oh wait no it's a just patch oh I thought she how did I just die what the flipping wait wait wait wait just walk back oh my god oh my god what is going on
You're supposed to be in here.
What is happening?
You just sit here for 10 seconds.
She's got to plop it up.
Wait, what does that?
Go feed my dog.
There's a mimic.
Sorry, that was my dog.
Oh my god.
Wait, how did you die, Snuffy?
There was an imposter.
Oh, so it was the mimic that got you.
He's, like, still walking around in the background.
We still want to still be able to move around.
Did we all die to the imposter?
Yes.
There was a fucking sniper at the bed.
Yeah, there was a bed guy.
There was a bed guy.
They were so sloppy.
They were like flooring the dog in the van and he shot me down
Maybe we should have just paid our rent
I I think we learned our lesson I think we can do I think we can okay we can make it we can make it Okay, we can make it Okay,
we got this we got this i believe It's so...
This is so crazy.
I think I got by a thing in the vent.
But there was like one point I saw...
It was like a TV monitor came from the ceiling.
It was crazy.
The glitch out was so good.
Bloody Mary.
What was that?
Yeah, Doki, what happened to me is that I...
I heard you scream.
I turned around and said, is that a scream important?
And then a red light scanned across the room and shot me down.
Oh, no.
I saw, like, a TV monitor come up from, like, the ceiling.
I think it was that.
Yeah.
Yeah, I think it was, like, an automated gun or something.
Something, yeah.
God, I don't know what reason.
There's, like, snipers there in the fucking bed?
But I'm sick, too.
All right.
Oh.
the logo.
Yes, I wanted to find the logo.
All right, I'm starting us up.
Okay.
What about what?
We got two orders.
I'm gonna make the thing for order two as well.
Okay.
I'm doing the one thing I'm good at.
I'm starting.
Oh, oh, there's buns on everywhere.
There's buns everywhere.
Wait.
do order one.
Order one.
All right.
Okay, okay, okay.
I can do either.
They're both three bergs.
Yeah, three bergs.
Paddies are coming in hot.
Coming in hot.
Burning my fingers.
Grabbing it with your fingers.
I put my face on.
Three.
Order two coming out.
All right, I'm grabbing.
Order three?
All right.
I'm doing order three.
Okay.
All right, order one.
gosh i love when they say plig love plig love makes me so happy what if that's like the slur it's not it's a good thing you don't have to use the other language plig love plig love plig love all right everybody has fries so i'm working on order four i'm getting your fries out for everybody i'll do four okay okay wait oh oh order three god get more patties on the other desk now i'll do order five more patties coming up coming up hot ouch ouch oops oops they won't know that it was on the ground probably yeah you can't see the kitchen it's five is three okay Alright,
order up.
A guy tried to catch me in his aura, but I was too far.
His aura.
Order six.
I doubt it.
That would be just what it is.
Order five, come on out!
Don't waste money.
Six.
With your aura.
Emo guy over here.
Play, play, play, play, play, play.
I robbed somebody.
I'm going to read a graphic.
I'm eating candy on the job!
Oh!
Oh, what happened?
Oh god!
Oh!
My sensitivity!
Are you good?
The candy!
Don't eat the candy!
She's having a trip right now!
She's having a trip!
I'll be fine.
I could move at exciting speeds.
Ready for order eight?
There you go.
I'm waiting for you.
I'm doing order nine.
Okay.
Can someone make me the drink for nine?
I'll make you the drink.
Thank you.
You are the drink.
I was just making sure.
It's a big discovery.
Thank you.
Uh-huh.
That's nine, right?
There's another.
You're so efficient.
We got another customer.
I got him.
I'll start it on a drink for him.
I'll put more candy for the running out again.
I have to try and get that guy trained without accidentally looking at him.
That's fucked up.
Uh-oh.
Someone doing ten?
I'm working on him.
Okay, I'll get you fries.
Thank you.
One patty, too late.
We need someone to kill some rats downstairs because we're like running out of patty.
No, you don't need so many freaking patty's, dokey.
What are you doing?
I'm out of the kitchen and there's 15 people.
Yeah, but we're sitting here for a day too.
What the rats will come?
The girls are fighting.
Oh, this is what Sloppy's has come to.
Oh,
slobby, we're just, we're slapping, oh, I think it's 100% last time, we're the fuck are our customers.
I pissed somebody off, though.
Yeah, one guy got his order wrong.
Oh, how did you make it mad?
What did you do?
That's not what I ordered.
Play blah, play blah.
Wait, what's that?
Oh, it can't.
candle.
This clort picture is like really freaking.
Okay, I'm missing a Nimi.
I guess we have time to redesign our bakery while we wait for customers.
Oh yeah, we need a logo.
Oh yeah.
There's so many patties.
What if we just ended the day and then did it again?
Are they going to be fresh for tomorrow?
Yeah, it'll be fresh for tomorrow.
It's made up out of rats.
It's made out of rats, so it's fine.
So it's fine, yeah.
They have like, 22 hour expiry date.
Fucking Christ, Doki.
It's weird way.
You made, like, the whole supply.
Oh, yeah.
Guys are running home on burgers.
Yeah, Doki was yelling at everyone being like, go shoot more rats!
And here are the bugs.
You need a bug catcher.
Oh, that's our logo.
Oh, wait.
You guys want to make the logo?
I think it should be a little rat.
Oh, that's true.
Do you guys remember how long like food can be at like, or meat can be at room temperature before it becomes a biohazard?
Just wondering.
In the game or in real life?
It has rat preservatives on it.
We're fine.
But it also attracts the actual rats.
That's why the rats want the patty's back, trying to bury the dead.
Oh, that's sad.
No, you know, if they did like those video science videos where like, um, they test out how fast, fast food rot.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
It's like, yeah, yeah.
In space, it never rots.
I'm ready for the next day if you guys are.
I'm ready.
I've restocked the fridge.
That's why.
It's totally for signing your logo.
We should learn.
I'm almost done.
Don't worry, guys.
Don't worry.
Yeah, I want to see our...
We'll be browsing.
Oh, oopsie.
I forgot to reset.
I'm fine.
I helped you.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, my gosh.
The last thing you would have seen.
That's on the patty.
Are you special foot lettuce?
Yeah.
Foot lettuce.
Number five.
It's okay.
I don't think there are food Ten inspectors in space, so it's fine.
Yeah.
Well, come.
There's two whole vats of fries just for minting as well.
They're fine.
The fries are fine.
You already know cereal fries tastes great.
I want some fries right now, guys.
Oh my gosh, I want a burger so bad!
I'm gonna get it.
I'm gonna do it.
I'm gonna get a burger, I'm gonna do it.
Nobody can stop me.
I'm gonna do it.
I'm gonna do it!
I'm gonna eat the rats!
what i think we can end the day yeah yippee let's go look at our logo look at the logo what's the logo what is it that's perfect oh here they come a train here they come here they come oh I like this guy he's kind of cute yeah but no shirt no shoes no service what the hell lint why don't we take his order You should go,
like, smooze him up.
You think he's cute?
I think he's into you too.
Oh, he's glancing this way!
He's glancing this way!
Next time that I learned a dual wheel.
You got this?
Here's our water.
He's nodding, he's nodding, he's nodding.
I do, I do.
Wait!
Snuffy, watch out for the aura!
No!
His aura.
11.
Somebody else.
I'm sorry, 11.
It's okay, you couldn't have known.
I'm working on 12.
How many was it?
Okay.
I have the soda done.
Thank you.
Two and two.
Five's here too.
We're getting two orders.
Thank you.
Don't wait.
I got more people.
Watch out, watch out, watch out.
There's a man.
Oh, wait a minute, get the gun, get the gun, get the gun, get the gun, get the gun!
Okay, no, it's...
That's fine.
Wait, is...
Uh...
Burger meat.
Okay, he's done.
Was he number 12 or...
No.
I'm gonna go take him downstairs.
Blah, blah, blah, you're welcome.
We're so welcome.
I look very home.
I got the orange soda.
Yeah, we got more customers.
We got a drippy guy too.
I got number I got ordered for 14 I got 15 I got 16 okay I'll order some buns time for the bun depot did I order oh did I total what is this what is this oh that's a pickle
Um...
How do I order...
Am I stupid?
How do I order it though?
17 going out!
16 going out!
I'm gonna go look at downstairs.
We got it.
Ah!
Bun box here.
I think it worked.
There we go, guys.
Technology is easy.
Oh, wait, honey.
I'm brewing.
What is that noise?
Oh, something sounds really loud.
Doing 19.
Could someone grab the mop?
Someone swore to know where they're playing.
I'm ordering more buns!
Okay.
I got more buns.
What?
Wrong way.
More buns.
Good thing there's no fall damage.
We got the buns.
We got the buns, hun.
Yeah.
I got buns!
My vision's a little distorted, which probably means bad is happening.
What's distorted?
I've noticed when something weird is happening, my vision goes wrong.
a word in game oh freaking you know it's the vents it's the vents you guys don't walk under the vents there is something in it you see him oh yeah there's goof over there yeah yeah Oh, I see it.
Yeah, I don't think it's killed by the gun.
Yeah, he can.
Oh, did you move?
Yeah, he moved.
I'll let you know if I see him.
I fucking hate working here, bro.
Hey, did you say you hate working here?
Wipe up those tears.
I'm not doing this because my mom said I had to.
Okay, who's doing 19?
Anybody doing 19?
No, I said 19 by episode already.
Okay, I'm doing 19.
We have many orders.
Hey, yeah, yeah.
Let's get into the hustle too.
I just heard somebody like gush all over the place.
Did somebody die?
The goop is dead.
Oh, the goop died.
Thank God.
Okay, who's working on what?
I got so many orders.
What's not being done?
Is 20, is 20 being done?
I'll do 23.
Oh, that's not mine.
Wait, you're still...
20 i think is anyone doing 20.
i'm done i did 19 i did 19.
i'm doing 20 then there is no 19.
stuffy in her imaginary numbers again
and then i think this is the drink fossil aid i think that's they're gone where's 19 they left 19 doesn't exist i'm doing 20.
I did 23.
Blip-blip-blip-blip-blip-blip-blip-blip-blip-blip.
22?
Is...
Nobody doing 22?
No, I don't think so.
No one's doing any orders right now.
Okay.
I'm doing 24.
22?
Two.
Uh-oh, what's that sound?
I'm doing 25 unless someone's doing it.
Oh, it's the Ben Man again.
That's the Ben Man.
Oh, my gosh.
That was a very good name.
Which one did you know?
Doing 25.
25 i'm doing 22.
um i'm doing 24.
i'm giving you guys patty's i'm going patty i'm on 25.
i'll do 26.
we're so efficient guys yeah look at us we're calling our orders out we're going doing this all right 22.
yeah is it you 22.
22 blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah Go get some patties!
I'll get patties!
Okay.
Alright.
Come on, rats.
Mommy's hungry.
I need somebody to help me.
Alright.
Number 19.
Minky footletters.
Alright.
Why do we keep calling these things rats?
I don't know, actually.
It says grab what?
Grab... Oh, meat...
Meature.
That's like a meat creature.
It's a meature.
Nice to meet you.
Can't wait to have you.
In my mouth.
Okay, but I hear rats.
Oh my gosh, there's so much...
Why can't I grab more than one thing at a time?
Ah!
Wait, what if I slipped and died right here?
Nobody would know my body was down here.
There's like a ton of stuff down there.
I'm singing.
Okay, patties.
They said they needed the patties.
Patties!
Patties up!
Hell yeah!
Hell yeah.
Patty, patty.
I'm doing my part.
i'm a team player everybody i do you are yeah i'm just throwing boxes
someone ordered literally every thing oh we're basically oh okay good the stack of boxes i know
what's haunted i fixed it i fixed it i'm delivering boxes please put in appropriate places
cheese cheese to meet you we in jenga now yeah you're a freak not you oh i guess i know no don't he's like we need more patties and we just fill it with two boxes and there's like eight on the side yeah Okay, I'm done delivering.
I don't want to do it anymore.
I'm bored.
I'll deliver.
I don't like it.
We got the tomatoes.
We're doing so well now.
I know.
Oh, we're getting back to work.
Oh, new day?
Oh, back to work.
I'm fine.
There's no breaks.
No breaks allowed.
No getting off this crazy train.
I'm doing the first one.
Except this is my break.
Guys, I used to work third shift at a fast food place.
It was hell.
But this could never compare.
Hi, hi.
Whoa.
Why did my screen get kind of weird?
Maybe it's somebody's birthday.
Did you take more candy?
No.
Are they waiters?
We do do.
yeah we just finished this one which ones are which ones are called do i need to do it i'm doing 38 38 38 there's only 30 there's no 38 i'm doing 30.
okay i'm doing 31.
yeah oh i do need glasses he's making burgers in the future okay to be fair it kind of what's on order 38 man what 32?
Am I doing 32?
Oh, 38?
We developed a new meat.
It's crazy.
It would never guess.
Play-plow, play-plow.
Now rat-free.
Who keeps making comic books?
Anyone on 33?
Uh-oh.
Wait, is there something wrong with the soda machine?
No.
It's haunted.
Um.
Leplon.
Not 32.
I use both bridges, guys.
I know when I'm up.
Doing 31.
Okay.
Um, I'm trying to do 34, but uh...
I'll do 35.
Okay, I'll do 34 then.
What's that sound?
What is that?
The vent man?
I don't know.
Two?
Sounds like the vent monster.
Yeah.
Something has spawned.
I think because my green just buzzed again.
So we ran out of patties.
I think...
We didn't run out of patties.
What are you talking about?
We ran out of patties.
The rats are here.
Can you put the rats in the...
Okay, let's kill one of the customers.
We need patties.
Okay, hold on.
Um, what am I supposed to do about this?
Who's doing order...
Which orders?
I'm trying to do 34, but I can't.
Oh.
Oh, um...
Yeah, I don't know what to do.
I don't know what to do.
Put a lid on it.
Oh If you just have to kill him Maybe we should just choose that guy to assassinate Because clearly he's not going to be happy So I got him Just like Silence 34
I'm doing 34 Who are you 34
That's like the longest P ever
I'm getting Oh Oh you got it You go for it Someone just tossed a tray at us But uh Wait, what's happening?
Is someone on 36?
Whoa.
Okay, I'm on 37.
What?
Okay, I will do 30.
I'll do 38.
I'll go do the power.
Oh.
The power's coming out.
Oh, no.
This isn't good.
I'm tripping on candy.
And the power's out.
Okay, we're fine.
What do you see?
Can't wait to see when you're tripping up?
Yeah, there's a- there's- Watch out, watch out, watch out!
Oh, I think someone died.
Um, is that the sniper?
No, oh, he's dead, he's dead.
Take what- Oh, she's dead too.
She took him down one bit.
Wait, okay, two...
It's shooting, it's shooting.
Two.
Two patty.
I can't tell what is a patty.
Oh, I'm returning the normal!
Oh my god!
It's... it's... it's Tobago!
Is this what it feels like to be colorblind?
No binds left!
Uh-oh.
Watch out!
The TV!
We're supposed to work in these conditions!
Oh my god, the TV is looking at us everywhere.
I think we need to shoot the TV, you guys!
He's yelling at me and I died!
Wait, what?
What is that?
Wait, our customer's shot?
What did she do?
No, no, the TV keeps shooting people.
If you can make the orders, I'll keep an eye out for the TV.
The TV killed me.
Oh, I think I'm back.
I'm gonna get them.
They're in a box.
Okay.
We have no buns left.
I can't do anything.
Yeah, we have no buns.
They're coming up.
Somebody's getting them.
Okay.
What's going on in here?
I think it's...
Buns go here.
Buns on the left.
One on each.
Oh no, no, you did the wrong one.
I ordered two sets.
It should be okay.
Okay.
Well, goodbye number 38.
Maybe.
I don't see... I'm mad right now.
We need more fries.
What the...
Was that a person?
a ghost they do okay okay wait i'm holding fry oh wait thank you oh oh thank you this is 38.
this is 38's bun i i don't know whatever it was yeah 38's bun 38 that's 38.
okay i need a tray oh wait that oh watch out watch out the thing is dripping it's dripping Okay, you got it.
You got it.
Did I get him?
No, I think it moved.
We have no more lids.
Order some lids.
I'll order lids.
This game is hard.
Oh, wait, it's in here!
Where's the gun?
Dang it.
I think it left.
I'm ordering lids.
Wait, the computer's occupied.
who's in here hello ghost ghost I banished thee
wait why are there two people dead guys no panic don't panic friends I have two hands
don't worry everybody return to your seats calmly are you sure you have It says you're dead.
Wait, it says I'm dead.
Are you dead?
Nokia, are you dead?
No, I'm alive.
I'm not gonna save this because I'll get a chance.
What's happening?
Nimmy, can you see me?
Yes.
And you can hear me?
I'm a ghost.
It says you're dead on my screen though.
Yeah.
Oh.
I wonder if I go in here if I'll revive.
No.
It still says you're dead, though.
It's so weird.
But it won't let me use the computer because I think it thinks I'm dead.
Yeah, we can't disappoint customers if we just close, right?
It doesn't count.
I don't know what we're supposed to do.
I'm so confused.
Oh, the day's over.
We disappointed everyone.
Okay, we gotta restock.
We have to restock, guys.
We are still running out of.
We're running out of.
What do we need?
Liz, Liz, Liz.
We're running out of Liz.
That's the only thing we're running out of.
It wouldn't let me use the computer.
That's weird.
Oh, now it'll let me.
I can't use it.
Yeah, I can use it.
Maybe I'm...
Uh-oh.
The power's going to...
I'm going?
Turn on the power?
Wait, what?
Oh!
Oh, you have to do a thing!
Yeah, okay, well...
Oh, okay.
Oop.
I didn't see the Simon says.
Everything's fine, you guys.
Everything's fine.
What's up?
What is this?
This is a cup.
I've got cups.
Restock cups.
The soda machine is our downfall, I have to say.
The day is over.
Wait, oh, our cups are full, that's why.
Um, I'll put it here.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, I did it!
Wait, we didn't get- we didn't get lids!
We didn't get lids!
They might be downstairs still!
We got cups.
Everything is buns!
Yeah, are you real?
Are you real?
That's not real!
That's a bad one!
Oh no shit, there's two of them!
Doki, speak!
No, it's a 19, but I have to say no.
Oh my god, thank god you make the right choice.
Ah!
Why won't it let me stalk anything?
Am I crazy?
This is cups.
Oh, we do have lids, just kidding.
Why did it say no lids, though?
Can anybody read the television?
Somebody's a fan?
Yeah, no, I can read it.
Wait, you can read it?
All right, well, I guess only live will can make sure it is.
Yeah, I know.
I can't see them.
I can't either.
Me too.
I'm gonna put more pat on it.
Wait, why is it a white screen?
You're on kitchen duty, live room.
Hey, V-bop.
There's some fries.
Thanks.
Let me know what you need.
The second one is one burger, one pickle, three tomatoes and that's it huh this order that's order 56 one burger one pickle three tomatoes three tomatoes tomatoes three tomatoes that's a lot of tomatoes i'm not going to read them out if you bigfoot are certain is that it that's all it is The game is breaking right now.
And what order was it?
56?
Playblow, playblow!
Lymo's feeling distressed.
No!
Oh, fast.
I got it.
It was down here.
Good job, good job.
I'll bring whatever this is too.
What did I grab?
I grabbed the bot.
More pods!
We don't need more buns.
Who ordered so many buns?
Wait, I don't have a weapon.
Blip-plop, blip-plop.
Who ordered so many buns?
That means...
We don't even need cheese.
Why don't we buy all this cheese?
What?
We're prepping.
It's called meal prep.
What is that?
I still can't see the monitor, so I don't know who's...
Oh, me neither.
I cannot... There's cups.
There's fries.
only one person can see the monitor but the fries in the bag why don't we deliver if Lymo is the only one that I can see she's literally the only one that can see the monitor why are you here she don't she quit she said screw this place I don't want to do this anymore but you're the best you're Lymo you definitely
I'm just telling you what number to deliver to and we'll deliver yeah okay i need fries and an orange soda all right i got the soda on here this tray here you go this tray okay what number is this 58.
soda 58.
someone's over i'll do it i'll do it i got it i got it i got it okay next one is 59 one burger one sheet oh god that's so complicated i did some i got more orders coming up wait this one's burned the game is breaking it's It says that we're dead and the things are falling apart.
Only one person can see the order.
I need fries.
Fries?
We got fries.
Oh.
Okay, 59.
I'm going out.
Order 60.
Three burgers, two tomatoes, and a dark cola thing.
Whatever that one is.
Dark cola, I got you.
Oh, it's haunted again.
Oh, it's not haunted.
Oh wait, there's two rats.
Put them in the shop.
Oh, there we go.
Uh-huh.
Is it fries too?
It's order number 60.
I'll see you go.
60.
Oh.
All right.
She's so fast.
61, 61.
Oh, the rats.
The rats.
They're the rats.
They're taking them.
Yeah, they're taking them.
Yeah, it's a tomato actually.
That's how fresh it is.
is all right what do you need kitchen manager limelight why did you shoot that guy wait am i crazy i just saw somebody get shot wait no no one got shot you're fine oh okay wait what's up what's up
is gone i'm gonna need pickles and an orange soda
are you nimi i'm nimi okay
nimi nightmare number 62 man can you take that out it's on the desk next to you 62.
which one is which one uh that one is 64.
two burgers won't hit what oh guys i found more patties Very convincing.
This is so sad.
We got dark patch.
We're doing so good.
I don't think...
Yeah.
Wait, what?
Because the acting party is in order number...
I don't see them.
67.
I believe so.
Okay, it's okay.
I have a set.
Blip blow, blip blow.
two cheese one tomorrow look at us all working there's like why do we sometimes have a million monsters and sometimes we have no monsters it does and that's order number 65 it's about to leave there good luck uh-oh the sniper a 66 to versus sniper sniper with a gun get the gun The gun's gone!
The gun's gone!
The gun's outside.
It's in the custom dining hall.
Why?
The gun is out here.
This is so doomed, you guys.
We're so screwed!
We're not screwed!
Um...
I don't see the gun.
Am I crazy?
It's over here.
I got it.
I have it.
I found it.
Grab it?
Oh, never.
Flour up on the floor.
Can someone sweep that up?
Okay, this one, please.
Order 69.
69, where?
Burger cheese, three tomatoes.
Yeah.
Burger, wait.
Burger cheese, three tomato.
Yes.
Oh, it says it's raw.
Three.
What the fuck is burger?
But it was raw.
is it just this okay 69 where are you and i'm so sorry that your order is late but it finally came tonight does the three cheese one pickle need anything else that's for the customer to make him
No, they won't!
We got 35 seconds.
Oh, we have 35?
Oh.
72, 73.
Oh, God.
Lymo.
Lymo, it's okay.
It's okay.
For some reason, you're so quiet for me.
Lymo, and you just keep getting quieter and quieter.
What?
No.
It's just busted.
It's busted.
Okay, the day's almost over.
Oh, sweet.
Bye, everybody.
I hope you guys enjoyed your day at coffee.
Get out.
You have to go and you can't stay here.
Go, go, go.
We need more tomatoes.
The vent has a monster in it.
Oh, the vent has the... Yeah.
Where's the gun?
Tomatoes, pickles, and cheese.
Oh, you got it?
Okay, good.
Okay, he left, though.
It's messed up that there's a vent in the break room.
Our score's not going down.
We're going up, up, up, up to the moon.
Wait, but we have money all of a sudden.
Oh, yeah, wait.
How do we...
We're good, actually.
How did we get 100% money?
I don't know.
How the fuck are we supposed to do this if I'm getting quieter and quieter and I'm the only one that can read the monster?
Sure, men just didn't take a funny little candy.
you guys should take a funny little yeah maybe you gotta take your edge off yeah oh yeah take it get it lymo get it oh my god she's trigger happy ah
chill there you go was that good it's good i might explode no no no what's happening everything's very dark am i okay oh no we're all here hard bro no i'm seeing i'm seeing a black and white man I wonder if she had a bad Oh look they left a yeah they left a tip Get a torch boat break in the kitchen Let's go guys come on I want another candy I'm addicted to that stuff I need my fix I need my candy fix what'd you get It was just a normal candy That's that's the good shit Oh you're no you're too immune to it now You'll never feel the effects again You gotta you gotta go to harder candies now You eating gum before now you got to eat like a like a jawbreaker yeah i gotta get those jawbreakers now bro it's not hitting it the same as before not getting that same hit yeah the gateway candy i gotta see that the gateway candy that's why i'll never touch a hubba yeah i heard that stuff's the worst it always it looks so innocent but then it It really just hooks you before you know it.
Yeah.
And then before you know it, you're spending your life savings on hubba-bubba.
And then you go from candy, and then not just candy, you'll go to pastries.
And that's when the real trouble.
You ever go double, double with hubba-bubba and juicy fruit and mix it together?
You're insane.
You're gonna choke on that one day.
Well, but the thing you hear me now.
you okay that's nice i'm glad yeah i can hear you i've always been able to hear you okay maybe we're slowly getting quieter and quieter i think it's just mine is bugged that's all yeah i think so too you because you were fine for me that's good okay let's see if you guys can see the monitor and if not we we just die because i'm not doing that again i cannot see the monitor i cannot like they're even blank wait wait we can take a oh that's right we have to take an order oh i can see i'm doing it i'm doing this one guys we still don't wait are you the answer is good idea i'm gonna kill the ad yeah they do respond oh okay that's good yeah they respond she was just killing customers for no reason wait she was murdering customers yeah Did she think you only get two ants for the entire game?
I think so.
Play, play, play, play, play.
Good job, good job.
I'm putting in a rapport for you.
Employee of the month.
I'll be 86.
Let's do an 85.
Input to a task.
Okay.
This guy loves lettuce.
I'm cleaning up like a good employee.
You guys, I think I'm going to be employee of the month, actually.
No effect.
Thank you.
What was that?
Surprise!
Oh my god.
What is doggy yelling about?
Are you okay?
Just like the rat, like, join the patty.
Oh yeah, they do that.
That's what they do.
This is a soda for 87.
Okay, who's working on what?
I'm working on 89.
Okay.
I'll do 86, or who's doing 85?
Anybody?
No?
Nope.
Okay.
I'm just flipping patties.
89.
There's a growth soda on the side.
85, 3, and 2 pickles.
Wait, I need another one.
There's two boxes of bad exterminator.
Alright.
85.
Oh!
Don't get mad at me.
Wait, who are you?
Wait, where'd 85 go?
Where'd 85 go?
Oh my god.
What?
Did he leave?
Oh, that's a big guy.
Thank you.
Wait, why can't I?
Two burgers, one, one, one, two on those, man.
Okay.
I got more.
Is anyone making 92?
It still says 85, though.
Yeah, but it's up for the rat.
85, wait, no, 87's being done here.
I'm making 92.
I'm making patties.
I got two enough, right?
Hey, what's been, what needs to be done?
I'll do 98.
92?
I'm doing 92.
Oh, you're doing it.
Okay, I'll do 93.
Was it 92?
Did I misread it again?
Oh, there is 92, yes.
Oh, it's 90.
Okay, I just did a drink for 90.
I keep reading the zeros.
I can't read.
Uh, two patty.
I'm...
Oh, no!
Okay, I got it.
Oh, I snuffing.
I got snub.
Snub.
Oh, come on.
Not take fry.
Okay, it's, uh...
One cheese.
Yeah, I'm doing 90.
I'm trying.
Oh, gosh.
There's an attempt.
It's so difficult!
I never did make my soda, hold on.
Uh, and that's it.
Okay.
Wait, oh!
Well, having zero gravity?
90.
Fire up!
90, 90, 90!
Where are you?
90!
Yeah, blah blah, blah, blah.
Wait, why is it still up there though?
Why are the orders not going away?
Oh, they are for me.
Oh, they're not going away for me.
Oh, my God.
Oh, dear.
Okay, I gotta shoot around.
You need me an orange soda?
Yep.
Okay.
Did anybody do 96?
No, I'm doing 90.
It's bugged again.
Oh, no.
They've all desynced.
They've desynced.
I don't know what I'm making anymore.
Oh!
There's an orange soda.
Oh, yeah, everything's decent.
Truly, that's some sort of like...
Oh, why are they raw?
Why are they raw?
I think we're fucked because the displays aren't updating properly.
We're so screwed!
Like, I keep seeing an order for ages and then it just randomly disappears.
Yeah, even the things that...
Like, 85 is still up.
Yeah.
In 92...
this is it this is how our restroom goes guys not with a bang but with a whimper okay i'll go get the gun i'll go down feeling good
the game is a little the game is in early access everybody
He bombed since when?
Let's just go.
Yes.
We're going out in style.
I think I'm actually immune to them now.
Where's the gun?
I just put it on.
Doki left it downstairs.
Careful, careful, careful.
The thing was in here a second ago.
Oh, okay.
Is it charging?
I see my smoke break.
Give me your neck.
Smoke break.
The game's not functioning anymore.
It is.
Oh, it's showing me orders.
Order one.
Order two.
There's so many.
You got the pool?
Yep.
I did my job.
I did it.
I'm good.
Number two.
We have no patties?
Oh.
okay who's working on what oh it came back yes and no I'm doing order one
huh it's just a little weird okay who's doing order order two is gonna do it two nope I'll do two Wow, we served so many people we looped back from a hundred.
Yeah, we're killing it, we're killing it.
We're killing it.
Oh, we got Shrek in here.
Oh, shit.
Someone just freaked out.
Why?
Oh!
You're stuck again?
I'm stuck again.
I'm using the gun.
Oh, I killed him.
Wait, what else is happening?
Oh, there's a big guy.
There's a big guy.
Uh-oh.
Oh, the day's over.
I still killed him.
Oh.
Impressive work.
Mr. Strong.
Mr. What?
Strong.
You're free!
I'm free!
How many patties do you think this guy is?
Why is Doki throwing Doki away?
No, I'm just...
If one feels just like a customer, I want to know what's right.
Wait, why is your body there?
Because I thought Doki would get grabbed.
But I didn't pay the bench, man.
I didn't pay the bench ball.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Whoa!
But again, he starts twerking.
I can't even grab, oh there we go.
Oh, that's scary.
Yep, yeah.
Woo, woo!
Woo!
Yeah!
Very good.
Do it again, Mr. Strong.
Did someone just pay the rent or did we just lose $400 for no reason?
No, I pay the rent.
Okay.
We paid the rent!
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Not enough.
I wish we could live amongst them.
I would say that the Sloppy sisters have moved on up.
Yeah, I think so too.
Also, Nimi did a lot of fry cooking, which is so appropriate, and I love that.
I know.
Our side of Nimi fries.
I love it.
Look at that, guys.
The franchise and the success, guys.
space look they're fighting like pokemon oh that's yeah fighting but they've actually the save stays intact if we didn't fail it so we can keep that for next time if you want oh yeah oh yeah definitely coming back yeah i thought i thought honestly if they like the working service and shooting it without the order screens i think it would be really good yeah oh oh not the both the lighting and going
into space
we're gonna move a burger after us the sloppy burger oh and the lights fucking turned off too yeah it all happened they're like you ain't leaving oh I heard you wanted to leave no no we're gonna turn the power off I'll turn it back on hey Hey.
Hey.
That's my job.
You just left.
I was the one who turned it on.
My brain is like, I gotta keep guys.
You can stop.
Snuffy, we're finishing.
We're done.
Oh my god, wait, but all these patties wasted.
They are wasted, but that's okay.
That's okay.
It's for the ride.
Here, here.
Here, you get one?
Yeah, I get one.
I get one on it.
Yeah.
Yeah, there you go.
Run me with the day.
Of course for you.
Wait, there's enough for everybody.
Let's burn this place down.
Wait.
Can we learn?
I don't think they work when the thing's off.
Dang.
Oh!
Thanks, Doki.
Oh, come on.
Whoa.
Who said that?
Oh.
Wait,
you're alive?
Yes.
We're the strongest.
Are you hiding behind me?
Ow!
No, no, no, no, no, no.
Oh, shit, I'm dead.
Give me a sec.
No, I don't.
Kill me in here.
I'll just revive!
Don't do it!
Oh dang it, I missed.
I don't want to play with a U.
I don't want to...
You're gonna cheat!
You're gonna use your FPS stuff!
You shot my leg, you didn't shoot my head.
Oh dang.
Yeah, go with.
Wait, where are you?
Oh.
Yeah, you gotta shoot me one.
I won't.
No!
I just wanted to end it.
We couldn't leave the purgatory.
Kill Doki.
Kill Doki, then we can end it.
Oh, sorry, Nimi!
Wait, what got me?
Oh, okay, I was collateral.
Ouch!
Why?
stop i think that kills people actually i don't you guys are dead
oh my gosh oh i'm about to die i'm about to die oh my gosh oh i'm about to die oh gosh and then there was one oh well not a bat limu is the strongest battle royale
oh oh oh oh know the game hello hello yeah i hear you i'm slowly unmuting people yeah yeah yeah i can't believe the manager lived in the end i can i can mine was truly the strongest why did you guys resist i was trying to free us from burglary i wanted to die by a different hand you know yeah who was you what who are you to decide my how I pass you still died you still I killed you though I killed you you still left I lived GG's it was an honor thank you very much for hanging it was a pleasure and honor to work at sloppies again in space oh yeah I had a wonderful time it was wonderful getting to hang with you as well for the first time It was awesome.
Thank you guys.
Thanks for having me.
Thanks for joining us.
Yeah.
It was so fun.
Maybe next time Severance will come out and then we should.
Yeah.
We'll play it.
Hopefully then Min can finally haunt us after Halloween.
For real.
Cool.
Thanks guys.
Thank you everybody.
Have a great night everyone.
It was a pleasure.
I took my hot tea.
Go for it.
Sorry, Lymo.
I didn't eat that.
What the fuck, Meg?
Microaggressions.
God damn.
You were the manager, Lymo.
You were you deserved it.
Wait, you killed us all.
We all talk smack when you turn corn.
We're like, God, that Lymo, she smells so good like a nice citrus.
What?
Even her face looks like a Lymo.
Yeah.
He's coming.
She's kind of, she smells kind of like a ferret.
I don't know.
I like the way it's like a ferret spell.
I think it's a good spell.
Yeah, you have aura.
Go sleep.
Yeah, it's like 2 a.m.
Well, it was 2 a.m.
Good night, everybody.
Good night, everyone.
That game was crazy.
Oh, my gosh.
It's like it took that restaurant game and like, whoa, whoa, sorry.
Lethal Company.
Like, all these, it's like it took those, all the friend slop games and threw it into one game.
Yay!
Yay, yay, yay, yay!
It was so silly.
It's like we leveled up from the first sloppy collab to, like, where we were still working at a restaurant, but we were, we've leveled up to aliens.
Thank you, Dorgo!
The glitching was so crazy.
Plipplop, plipplop, plipplop, plipplop, everybody.
Thank you very much.
I hope you had fun.
yeah the game like completely fell apart on us on on us we had to rely on Lymu and then we couldn't rely on anyone we uh Lymu and I were dead but we weren't and the computer was occupied but it wasn't and I was slipping but I wasn't everything was happening crazy crazy crazy anyways thank you guys so much and i will see you when i see you next i'm i'm sleepy that that game wore me out so i'm gonna go rest and i suggest you all do the same oh it's a bito thanks for the fun collab thank you thanks for guys for hanging out for any naplings uh joined my pov thank you so much um uh yeah
Bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye.
Bye-bye.